now
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive
host an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
david patman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah
male 1 they think and act like a woman
they are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse well we gotta that's a
lot
that's a lot we with everything that's
raw abortion they think and act just
like a woman a beta male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is
[Music]
david patman he is
david patman he is
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking
bizarre questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right
[Music]
that's a progressive vote all men
[Music]
[Music]
of the sexual experience would ask the
young lady who's your
daddy this should be remixed if officer
akimov
is watching this could be the next remix
masterpiece dude because just wait till
you see what happens here oh officer
officer akimov is here
uh that's beautiful
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
manning
no i'm a christian
[Music]
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth
to reverence the word of god to trust
it to preach it to teach it
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of lies what happened
in prison that brought you to jesus
[Music]
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush senior and george bush
junior have been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem
oh i got down on my knees
[Music]
and tons and tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done
except they've done it we've seen them
that certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
how do you know that it flavors the
coffee gays tend to love each other's
[Music]
semen
[Music]
all right welcome everybody that uh
reliving that viral moment
from the pastor james david manning
jr maybe um
uh interview from uh quite some time ago
so welcome to everybody we do have
another uh trump rally on our hands
today
right side broadcasting uh is carrying
it via facebook because they've been
banned from youtube we're also
monitoring
a news max feed where oh it looks like
pastor ted nugent
jr is currently speaking uh the big news
of course that donald trump
told sean hannity the other day he has
decided about whether he will or won't
run in 2024.
um there is speculation
that trump may tell us what his decision
is
today i actually have that uh let's take
a look
and see uh no this is cognitive test
material where did i
ah here it is let's take a look at this
and i think i have most elements working
here
um let's see if we can listen and i've
got my volume
knob and okay let's see we don't have a
lot of time
but let's talk about your future plans
did you hear that what was that noise it
sounded like a bird in the background
did you guys hear that
we don't have a lot of time but let's
talk about
your future plans oh i guess someone was
sad that there's not a lot of time left
or something
now i have a fun
let me ask the crowd of everybody here
would you like to see the president
running in in 2024
the president by the way
[Applause]
you're not going to answer but i have to
ask
where are you in the process of or have
let me ask you this without giving the
answer what the answer is
have you made up your mind yes
now why people are cheering if we don't
know what the answer is
i don't know but these people will cheer
for anything
[Music]
i think you got it right yeah okay so uh
so trump has
has made up his mind let's close that
out um
and he may reveal today at the rally
uh what that decision is
and we will be we will be hearing about
that shortly
okay let's see this is a i'm gonna try
to do the best i can with super chats
and we have them on screen here
let me see what's the right way to do
this i'm just i'm just tweaking things
on the fly
we'll give a little bit more padding at
the bottom i don't know that we need
this but maybe we'll just make it a
little bit bigger
there we go okay let me actually look at
a few
super chats because so many are coming
in uh denver mccarthy says david i'm
i'm sorry i drunk dialed your voicemail
we might get to some voicemails
jimmy from philly here mixing it up says
your future president
i don't know who you mean zachary says
some alarmists are saying the worst is
yet to come
while the cdc and others are saying la
county's mask mandate is theater theater
and over cautious what are your thoughts
i will have a full
assessment of that on tuesday what is
this big dangerous buffoon
going to gonna mind vomit out of his
mouth today
maybe that he's running in 24. we're
standing by for that
without saying what the answer is have
you decided if there will be any live
streams next week beautiful
i have made a decision about next week's
live streams
i i am not announcing it but i have made
it and
uh ben shapirod says donald trump will
be delivering an unhinged rant from the
i shouldn't have blocked
the super chats with my mic that's kind
of that's bad planning hold on
trump will be delivering an unhinged
rant from the macho man randy savage's
hometown of sarasota florida it'll be
the cream of the crap baby so step into
a slim gym
oh yeah massive dumps okay and miter
says you're my kind of nerd mashup was
sick beth best fourth of
july and f trump okay good all right so
super chats are working
and we've got them coming in let's just
listen to a few seconds of what's
happening at the rally oh and they so
by the way last rally there was not
uh a black or or uh
latino person in sight and so
at this rally they've strategically
placed blacks for
trump right over trump's left shoulder
and looks like an asian guy and
two racially ambiguous women i guess
could be you know uh
could i don't even know anyway you guys
get the point of what's going on here
let's listen an absentee verification
you know why because when states like
florida have voter id
okay so just doing the typical typical
stuff and then here is a pre-rally
uh thing happening with the newsmax as
well so we're monitoring
all of it okay monitoring all of it you
know it it's sort of
sad but a few people already got banned
today
even before we started the stream which
is crazy it did
when people get banned before we even
start it's not a great sign
it's not a great sign but it did happen
um
oh people are saying also that my audio
is out of sync
with my video that actually could be if
you guys can help me test it
i'm going to clap okay and what we need
to fix i need i haven't made that
adjustment yet which i i do need to do
um when i clap tell me whether you're
seeing my hands come together oh it's
fine actually oh okay then i won't even
adjust it that's great okay
then i won't even touch it forget about
it
forget about it okay good um
all right other super chats no super
chats are good i won't change the i
won't do any uh any changes
perfect okay good um i do want to say
thank you
to the freak as well as libra girl and
mfrazzled
for signing up via twitch uh very much
appreciate that we actually have two
different coupon codes today we're
celebrating two different when that's
really celebrating
if you're most titillated
by this sad trump rally
you can sign up on my website with the
coupon code sad
trump okay that's one option
if you're more titillated by the
indictment on 15 felony counts of
trump's cfo
you can sign up on my website with the
code indictment 21
it's your choice you can do either
everybody
will get a big thank you from me and
in fact let me just make sure that we
have
i want to make sure i've added extra
internet tubes to the website today
because uh when i don't sometimes people
trying to sign up
we'll crash the site and we definitely
don't want that today
we definitely don't want that today uh
yeah okay we've amped everything up so
it should be pretty good
excellent excellent excellent we may run
out of coupon codes that's actually true
yeah that that that may happen
okay let me get to a few other things
that i had for you while we stand by
these are just various videos of people
early today lining up for the trump
rally this was
9 a.m so almost 12 hours ago you had
people already lined up can you imagine
nine o'clock in the morning
hours before he gets here not something
i would be bragging about
here's a line of trump supporters
i i it's hard for me to imagine a worse
place to be
yeah let's see what other videos there
are
uh video of the confederate flag display
outside of the trump rally today
oh yeah okay so we've got what one two
three four
confederate flags three thin blue line
flags
okay that's a historic uh flag by the
way that's that's the meaning of it it's
all about history um
[Music]
oh and matt gates spoke earlier we took
a little bit of that just welcome
congressman matt gates
volume's a tad low on that
[Applause]
actually maybe his voice will be louder
[Applause]
i thought trump was trying to distance
from gates actually it's i'm actually
surprised he was here
i'm not going to lie after the last few
months i needed that
thank you florida
again i'm a canceled man in some corners
of the internet
a marked man in congress maybe a wanted
man by the deep state
but in the core of my the deep state
what bones
i'm a florida man and it's good to be
home
they come for the fighters don't they
and so i have a message to uh for all
who need to hear it
for the country i love for the president
who inspires me
and for the people who send me to fight
in congress i have not yet begun to
fight
well you've not been charged yet right i
mean i guess that's part of it
uh okay so there's that um
very strange stuff i want to say thank
you to sn
corbett for signing up via twitch prime
i appreciate that
i'm also kicking us off today with the
coupon code
sad trump caitlyn
jorkowski caitlyn yorkowski
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code sad
trump you've gotta love it you've gotta
love it
uh okay do people want to hear a few
voicemails first or do we want actually
let's look at a couple more clips first
um oh after the indictment of trump's
cfo
eric trump went on tv and just said all
sorts of things that make no sense let's
listen to it a little bit
yeah well these are employment perks
these are
you know these are um you know a
corporate car which everybody has i
guarantee you there's people on this
network that have corporate cars i
guarantee you there's people in every
company in the country that have
corporate vehicles this yeah who doesn't
have a corporate vehicle guys
this is what they're going after this
isn't a criminal matter this is you know
it's really interesting raymond
after now it's actually eve so of course
what he's saying
is is not true in the sense that it's
it's dramatically oh hold on do i need a
little more uh
a little more brightness i can do that
hold on
i'm dealing with a sort of complex
lighting situation let's do a little bit
more
uh do i need more gamma no gamma doesn't
seem to be helping maybe just a hair
more contrast
uh okay there we go um
even if you're like the the cost if you
have a
what you know a corporate lease the
value of the lease needs to be added to
your income and you pay you're supposed
to pay taxes on it like
even if that's all that this was doing
that for 15 years
is already a problem of course that's
not what it is he's just lying
the financial crisis right they didn't
go after a single person on wall street
despite the fact that these people were
literally they took down the us economy
but they'll go down they'll go after
somebody after
fringe employment benefits is that
really what the dea is focused on as
little girls are getting shot in the
middle of times square they'll go after
a corporate vehicle and a corporate
apartment
give me a break and honestly i have to
say the media has actually been very
fair about this in the new york times
you know so many of the different news
outlets they've literally said this
isn't
this isn't criminal this isn't worth 40
or 50 investigators and
it did it all right so there's eric
trump's opinion about whether
their own uh cfo should be indicted i
think this is a different clip let's see
if the i think this is something else
certainly that they may send in tonight
indictment you're away your brother's
way or your sister's way
you know what i'm not eric because guess
what you know we've always lived
amazingly clean lives and believe me if
they could have they already would have
right i mean that's what they wanted
that was their end goal
you know the difference is i'm not
hunter biden i'm not selling paintings
to undisclosed people for half a million
dollars a piece i'm not doing
you know drugs in in in shady hotels
i'm not he does right doing them at
non-shady hotels would be fine i'm not
going out and soliciting prostitution
and i'm not going out and
you know selling influence to ukraine
and china and having lavish trips paid
for
while you know my father is commander in
chief no i'm not doing that you know
what we do
don ivanka and i live really you know
nice clean lives and we work very very
hard and guess what
long before politics ever came into you
know our lives
we were in the business world and we
were successful and we worked very hard
and we lived clean lives it was very
different than the bidens
that were never in business until their
father actually got into politics and
and they've milked it for everything
it's worth and they still do it to this
day and
you know eric where is the d.a there you
know when you have text messages of
of he sounds unhinged like he's not
making any sense
prostitutes and hard drugs and money
laundering and all these other things
that are on hunter biden's laptop that
have been
reported you know apparently by the way
air is this eric bowling he looks
completely irrecognizable to me it's
bizarre
they reported so many different times
where where's the district attorney
and where is the attorney general and
dude there's like jack nicholson in uh
1989 batman or 91 batman scales of
justice only go one
okay all right so that's that and then
um
oh yeah this is funny this is trump
during that interview let's just make
sure we're not missing anything we're
not
um during that interview uh last week
with uh sean hannity
during which trump said he had announced
well rather he had decided whether he's
running
um trump going back to the cognitive
test i'm in trouble with this
we aced it i can say that i aced it did
he get one
he didn't get one question wrong did he
30 out of 30.
wow yeah this crowd really
will applause applaud for anything and
they did get a little more difficult
after you got by 15 i would say but
i heard the first three questions are is
it a giraffe or an elephant right
well you know that's what the fact is
they take the first two or three
questions and they put that
and they put them in but let me tell you
they would not get those last
15 right certainly not the last 10 that
i can tell you but
anyway but yeah um i mean if you
if you only got 15 out of 30 on that
test
you're you're probably suffering from
pretty significant dementia
so the idea that he says nobody around
him no nobody would
what are you talking about dude just
bizarre we've gotten to the mike pillow
uh portion of the pre-trump rally we're
monitoring
right side broadcasting network this is
oh this is happening at the rally let's
see
and again when we get the house back in
18 months we'll fire pelosi
and then it's on to 2024. what do you
think about nancy pelosi and the
so-called
are they saying per losing date um
january
6. well it's pure it's pure politics
pure partisanship
it's another witch hunt i'm focused on
how do we move the country forward and
get back to an america first agenda and
right
how do you feel about it and that's a
completely reasonable jacket to be
saying that during yeah
while you're wearing yeah okay good let
me uh oh hold on a second i i'm
i'm apologizing i'm not thanking
everybody who's supporting the stream
arrivals one plays and k
shreds have both just subscribed via
twitch prime i really appreciate that
also want to say a big thank you jean
francois
ra who just signed up with the coupon
code
sad trump and stephanie gilstrap just
signing up on my website with the coupon
code sad trump
because these rallies are so sad they're
basically pity parties for the guy who
lost
and lost badly we have launched
an honorary coupon code sad trump all
one word all lower case it's on my
website
while supplies last we may run out of
these codes
the way things are going we may run out
of them very soon um
and you can sign up at joinpacman.com i
will thank you i will sing your praises
i will probably even be too effusive
in my praise but that's okay all right
let's get to some super chats if you
have a question a comment for me
let's get to it bridgette says think
hard but don't think long
pim tool says david in principle i agree
but contextually your utilitarian
framework allows a reductive cancel
culture to emerge
critical identitarianism yeah well said
well said pim please put on closed
captioning
okay i don't know how good it will be
and i don't know if they have it uh
let's see
auto-generated captions on i guess no
one's speaking right now is that what's
going on name you what and it's just
really cool to have yes they are i don't
know
all right well i don't know we're we're
monitoring everything
let's see michael says david one of the
black supporters was in a cult
led by yahweh ben yahweh maurice
woodside that sounds bonkers
david domini fowler says i think you
should move your audio by about 80
milliseconds
it's fine to the untrained eye do i want
to do plus
80 or minus 80. let me know jeffrey says
my god those trumpists will never get
those 11 hours back
kane feldus says how much do you think
the guy in uniform is going to get into
how much trouble standing right behind
the speaker
let's see oh i missed it i'm sorry we'll
get back to him i'm sure
uh what else do we have andreas says
according to stormy
dawn is always early wow
hey david whatever happened to the
singing duo camille and haley
i have no idea they did the vote trump
2020 song yeah i have no idea
they may be they may be dead i've
noticed more of my neighbors in the
suburbs of milwaukee raise up don't
tread on me flags
as their trump signs disappeared yeah
i've also seen trump 2020 signs replaced
with
trump 2024 signs
maddie says the least believable part of
the interview is that eric trump has
never paid for sex well said
trump is only relevant because media
legitimizes him stop giving him
attention that's how you deal with the
narcissist
yeah listen i think if he runs in 2024
he has a really good shot of winning
and the entire republican party is
essentially behind him so i think to
ignore him
is silly i think so it's to ignore half
of what's empirically happening in the
country right now
i can't do that in good faith
phil says what do you make of the whole
transports debate
you know i've talked about that a bunch
of times before i don't really want to
get into it
kind of in a vacuum right now um
i've got a bunch of clips on that and
james asks david have you seen the new
york times 1
6 video i yeah i think we looked at it
on on a stream
previously um
but we we may we may look at that again
all right thank you very much also want
to say thank you to taylor barry
taylor berry signing up on my website
with the coupon code
indictment 21 in honor of trump's cfo
being indicted on
15 15 15 felony counts
which is wild also thanks to ms
v taco weasel and milan
josek there is a hype train a lot of
hype happening on twitch right now
a beautiful time to re-up let's get to
some voicemails okay
because we've been on break i have 200
voicemails i've not listened to
um i'm gonna go through them one by one
just so people don't think i'm
cherry-picking the voicemails
i'm just scrolling back a ways here all
right let's just uh
let's just start listening to some of
these here
here we go hey i had a quick question
i was wondering with the recent
developments of rudy giuliani getting
his
license suspended by the uh
okay then they called back please ignore
my
previous message words are hard um i
didn't have this written down but
anyways here is my question
with the recent development of rudy
giuliani's law license suspended from
new york courts
i wanted to hear your take on a question
that i have why did it take them
this long to make this decision because
the investigation
was uh was everything was being
obstructed and i think that
they felt at until they could really do
a full
uh analysis they just were not going to
i guess i mean it doesn't really make a
lot of sense to me
but i don't know all right here's
another voicemail
hi david this is the virgin mary
okay i know you probably think i'm a
crazy person i know you were wrinkle
star and you've got
cleaving soul and there's many people
who have had that
who have that i i have pictures and
examples i know roger waters
is uh a man named scott ritsuma all
right let's listen to kimberly guilfoyle
i don't know who's crazier the caller or
kimberly he's doing exactly what we need
to do we need all of our leaders to be
standing up
and be reminding and start reminding the
american people why this is the greatest
nation that has ever existed
it is certainly the reason why i'm
running for senate here
they're not carrying her audio maybe
they're running it here please take a
moment to pray for them
for their families for the loved ones
for the people waiting for answers
tonight
we stand with them united in god
and in prayer amen oh my god
it's already crazy thank you
well florida who is excited to see the
45th
president of the united states
you can never get enough trump you know
what i mean
just ask the media
but we do love this state and we are all
proud to call it
our home we have relocated here with our
children
with our families because you know what
florida
is trump country
would he win by a quarter of a percent
or something this state
not because of the low taxes it's pretty
good though right
but president trump did that for the
country as well
and not because of the weather lol
a little bit rough today but look at you
guys you're shiny and bright and new
i love it and not just because of the
great educational
options here like they kept their
schools
open right yeah
and not just because how freedom and
liberty
are protected we love florida because
of all of you thank you florida
thank you for always being there for
president trump and for this country
it was pretty sad but please don't tell
texas
we don't want them to get their feelings
hurt a little bit right
very slurry yeah but i am quite frankly
certain that there
is not a better place to
celebrate 4th of july and america
than the state of florida
it's starting to amplify and that is
because
florida knows what makes
america great
[Applause]
but it's not all sunshine and rainbows
here's the bummer part oh boy
somehow joe biden
is in the white house
this strange hair i'm noticing an old
joe is leading from behind with
carmilla trying to push him down the
stairs
and joe's busy falling up the stairs
oh man people are being banned here well
but i tell you it just makes us miss
president trump even more
[Applause]
well with joe biden bumbling through
his presidency we have president trump
working harder and smarter every single
day
for the america first policies biden's
bumbling through his presidency
with higher approval than trump had on
even one day
uh a successful vaccination program and
record stock market numbers
he's just getting started
these people keep trying to write the
maga
obituary well we
just keep writing american
history with president trump
what is she talking about they want
america to believe that the conservative
movement is fractured is
divided they want america to believe
that this movement is dead
well we got a full gas why does anybody
know why she's speaking so slowly
[Applause]
deal with it liberals deal with it
democrats
we are going to take back the house
and rip the gavel from nancy pelosi's
hand
we are going to crush it in the senate
and we will take back
the white house
oh you know they're silent screaming
inside so why won't those people just go
away
i don't think so hmm
it's pink slips to those liberals to the
democrats and for
those that would try to step on the
dreams
of hard freedom working and loving
americans
the hard-working americans that the rest
of the country and the politicians left
behind
but one man stood for each and every one
of you
and your family president trump
the most incredible president this
country
has ever seen this is really humiliating
yeah this guy in the military uniform
huh
[Applause]
and it is a sea of patriots here today
and the millions across
this country who are not going to be
silenced
and we definitely are not going to see
this fight to the socialists
to the communists and to the liberals
that want to destroy it certainly won't
be seated to the communists or
socialists since there's essentially
none in any position of power
line with us
[Applause]
the fight for liberty the fight for our
conservative values
and the fight for the heart and the soul
of this nation
will not be abandoned
president trump will not let that
happen and neither will you all right
[Applause]
we can never give up on america don't do
it
she's worth it each and every one of you
are worth it in your family and your
children
we are going to continue to fight
because we have someone that loves this
family
of americans and will continue to fight
for this country
thank you for your service and
dedication president trump
we will always stand with you
[Applause]
i have great news because the republican
party is being reborn under the
leadership of president
trump it's born again in a sense
it's going to be this is being reborn as
the party of the working class
this is the party of america first the
party of president trump and this
big beautiful movement that he
created oh my god you guys see this
guy's beard right here
i want to say goodbye
to the weak need spineless and the
coward
politicians that have failed this
country
people wondering who this is this is don
jr's girlfriend
thanks to president trump we have great
leaders
great fighters like the governor of the
great state of florida
ron desantis
yikes president trump created a unified
movement that is here to stay and is
growing brighter and
stronger every single day
we will chart a new path in american
political history
a path driven by bold i'm fascinated the
people
i'm trying to figure out who who seems
to be most out of their minds of the
people standing behind her
it's tough a path where we don't bend
the knee
to the demands of the leftist mob
and a path where we are willing to stand
up and fight for what
we hold dear with the help of god
from california to new york this guy's a
top competitor yeah
back this country
yeah people in the chat saying desantis
is really a threat he he is i've said
before desantis is someone with all the
bad instincts of trump
and less incompetence he is a dangerous
guy and yes we are doing mercy bans
today if anybody wants to be banned
for mercy just ask the moderators can do
it
washington d.c because we need
fighters like president trump in this
country
we need warriors like president
trump in this country and
with your help and with president trump
we
will save america
our movement must stay true guys i gotta
tell you
i'm not saying any i don't know what
i i have no further meaning to this the
three blacks for trump guys
don't seem very into this and they
almost seem to be looking for the exits
it's just a little strange i don't know
our nation
is based on putting the american
worker and the american family
first
finally we must and we will take
our movement and our message to every
corner of our nation
america first means all of america
our ideas our conservative values
and the solutions we champion are the
key
to lifting all americans up
president trump did that for this
country
with the help of god he will continue to
do it
every single day
as a movement our message must transcend
party lines socioeconomic lines
and cultural lines
yatsusave
oh dear god i'm not even sure that's
legal promise you
winning elections all of
them that's giga yikes
happened because you guys know i'm a
native spanish speaker i thought she was
maybe
speaking some kind of uh like aboriginal
type language
then i realized she's speaking spanish
florida
god bless governor desantis and his wife
our beautiful
first lady god bless president trump
first lady melania trump and the whole
family
are military did you say farts lady our
police officers and first responders
we stand with you and most importantly
stand and love this country and this
flag and what she stands for god bless
america
and please welcome the son of the former
president of the united states
donald trump jr
all right so here comes don jr i do want
it this is so traumatic in
a lot of ways i do want to make sure
everybody who's here and supporting gets
a thank you thanks to splashmuk blakey
stakey sir rock as well as hey michael
um all four of you signing up via twitch
prime putting us at 17.
because this is so sad right the
the if you want to do anything to
support our oh
god if you want to support our work grab
a membership on my website
joinpakman.com today you can use the
coupon code
sad trump to get a huge discount it's
legal in most states
um leslie young just did that and is new
member number 18
today leslie thank you so much and i
invite you to go to joinpacman.com i
will thank absolutely everybody
and let's now uh continue with don
jr after he's done then we will i will
thank more people
i'm going to put some super chats up on
the screen now keep those coming let's
listen
than that
and since it's america's birthday
happy birthday america
oh man it's so nice to be here in
florida when you say that stuff in new
york they say
what i i don't understand what's going
on here
but guys we've had about six months
of joe biden
i know i know i told you so
record vaccination record low cases
record low deaths record stock market
it's really bad guys we'll save a
cumulative
16 cents oh here we go
on your barbecue
right 16 cents for your whole family
that's great as long as you don't have
to drive
to the end of your driveway
in which case the extra dollar per
gallon of fuel
will eat up that 16 cents right you go
about
seven yards and it's over okay
hey guys what what is he talking about
what on earth is he talking about
for the picnic table it's over
if you have a brain and you've used your
wallet in the last couple of weeks you
know that it's nonsense
but it won't stop them from pandering
because that's all they're capable of
doing
right china this
sort of hard to believe right what i
want to know
media where are all the russia
russia russia folks
right joe's giving vladimir putin
pipelines
joe's canceling aid packages to the
ukraine
wrong and if i was correct
guys i was told that that
is an impeachable offense to even
discuss it right
it's all fake news it's phony stuff
you can't have that conversation
let alone do it but they're okay
and even worse the media
when vladimir putin said no no joe biden
sounds really sharp he's really with
it wrong
really the media points to vladimir
putin saying no
no see of course vladimir putin's going
to say that
he's dealing with a [ __ ] he's getting
everything that he wants
wrong he's eating our lunch
i i genuinely don't know what he's
talking about he's been doing this a lot
lately in interviews where it's like
what
what is even the general topic of what's
happening right now
get up little boy go sit in your corner
joe we've already discussed that
now we already introduced the president
of south africa
about seven seconds ago but you can't
remember that far back
okay we we feel bad for joe
right i mean i do
if i couldn't remember seven seconds ago
it's a problem
it's a bigger problem that he's in
charge of the nuclear football
george uh thanks to kenickia as well as
sticky
green dragon montessori maddie one
and six lj for supporting the stream via
twitch we're standing by
for donald trump a senior blacks for
trump
have been strategically placed on stage
as well as you might have noticed they
moved the gentleman in the military
uniform as well to put him in a prime
position
so they're really strategically setting
all of this up we are celebrating the
sadness of this event with an exclusive
coupon code
sad trump you can support the stream
right now on
my website joinpakman.com you will get a
thank you
katie throne just signed up with the
code
sad trump sam seely
just signed up with the code sad trump
and so we press
on to 100. what will happen first
trump will say something xenophobic it
comes from
china or we will get to 100. it's a race
it's not clear which will happen first
molar hoax
ukraine hoax don jr commit we're on like
version 15
of russia russia russia right now
just this week it's never going to stop
because that's what the democrats do
right all the things
that were conspiracies
right you know the difference between a
conspiracy and the truth
these days about six months
right okay
please fact jack that one cnn please
i'm begging you right
oh trump was right right he was right
about wuhan lab
no but seriously at what point
true story
hey i mean china
there's like 30 000 people here we have
45 000 reservations i assume
wait a second he's not really claiming
there's 30 000 people at that rally is
he
are they doing this again
but joe biden definitely got 81 million
legitimate votes
81 billion
hide
no guys guys it was the most secure
election in history
he seems to be having a medical event
just this week
just this week in a new york mayoral
democrat primary they screwed up 135
000 votes in new york city alone
but it was definitely and definitely did
not happen anywhere else
an election that could have been changed
by less than 45
000 votes it definitely didn't happen
it's the most secure ever
and if you believe that i have some
oceanfront property in colorado for you
okay
i wrote a book about liberal privilege
all of those things have unfortunately
come
true he really has a way with words i
want to say thanks to it's me john b
dirt knapp lady to groan as well as
beta star jeff and boston just gifted
five subs want to say thanks to hey quiz
lol
uh that's uh 10 i think putting us at
34.
super strong also i can't avoid
thanking jeff callahan who just signed
up on my website with the code
sad trump troy smith signed up with the
code
sad trump joshua kate's taking advantage
of the
immoral but legal coupon code rob
fenwick
signing up and elizabeth preston as well
thanks very much
we are bemoaning the sadness
of this horrible horrible trump event
it has not been easy for me and you know
i i started off in brooklyn my father
gave me a small loan of a million
dollars
yeah and so you can use the coupon code
sad trump
to uh get a membership on my website i
will thank you
and then uh trump will slur and say
things that don't make any sense that's
basically the plan for the night
longer have to abide by the rules of
math or science
the rules of physics no longer apply if
it's not bolstered by a mainstream media
who probably never took physics
that doesn't matter anymore it's about
narrative right that's how science works
it's not about fact it's about what the
democrat party
and their marketing arm the media
would like to be true
think of the damage that done
look at the clown anthony fauci right he
was made a deity
oh no oh no
[Music]
excuse me where's the lobby down the
hall grabbing by the [ __ ] thanks
well guys if you read his emails
it's clear he either doesn't believe in
science
and now there's a mic pillow ad
alongside can you imagine
we need to fight that uh we need to
fight that code with our own code
sad trump imagine going after a doctor
he wanted to be loved
he wanted to throw out the first pitch
at a baseball game that didn't work out
so well
unfortunately for america
for your families for your businesses or
your places of work it didn't work out
well either
just it looks like just the feed of don
is frozen because the audio's fine
and the graphic oh there we go it's like
he's the mvp
of a baseball game but he's playing for
china
[Music]
true china right
who's going to parlay this one into a
win and guess what joe will do
nothing because i'm sure they're gonna
get return
on investment from all the money they
sunk into hunter biden
what on earth is he talking about that's
how it works folks
so trump was right about that
he was right about russia he was right
about joe he was right about
what else will trump be found out to be
right about
stop it
[Music]
everything right kamala harris and the
media try blaming the border crisis on
trump
still with the kamala stuff time for
sleep just gifted 20 subs on twitch
also thanks to sumi long ignatz hd
and owen rock uh 23 plus 39 that's got
to be like
62 or something like that also big thank
you to carol
jones for signing up on my website
tonsurey bryant
is a new member whoa huge huge
uh dump of memberships dr gorka has just
signed up
pedro salinas is a new member marissa
terrazovich
as well as john moorer um
oh whoa hold on a second angela pagano
signing up with the code sad trump phil
parker as well putting us at 68. um what
a night what a night as
if you're just joining us trump speaking
momentarily he has reportedly
decided about whether he's running in
2024 we don't know if he'll
announce it today but he has decided
and um that's what's happening at this
point
80 miles just so they don't cancel me
for exaggerating
right from where the real crisis is
right
i can't remember who built the cages
but it's funny you wouldn't know that
don't be rude situation is going on
except it's about
times a thousand probably a lot more
kids living on top of one another
right covered let's maybe go over the
other feed
so the same situation
is going on except it's about it's about
times a thousand here we go probably a
lot more
kids living on top of one another
right coveted environments they're not
testing them
release them into the american public
that's better than deporting them right
who cares if they have covet i mean
that's been this administration's policy
they're leading from behind and the only
people
who are winning are china russia
our enemies china right you saw the news
about new york this week
the political persecutions will continue
because basically
we are no different than russia
we are no different than the mullahs in
iran
right this is how vladimir putin treats
their enemies right
yeah sure some charges keep going
we'll break just keep going
doesn't matter because there's no
consequence there's no accountability
and you see it in the result i thought
it was the mullahs
i've never heard of the mullahs but
that's i mean i
i that i'm not as well versed in foreign
policy as don jr
they got it all right
i hope they're okay i hear the medics
are on their way but
i just want to thank all of what
happened okay you came out here it was
100 degrees for hours and you got rained
on for
right this is how vladimir putin treats
their enemies right
we'll go back to live in a second some
charges
keep going we'll break
just keep going doesn't matter because
there's no consequence
there's no accountability and you see it
in the results
[Music]
guys we need a medic is there a medic
here
oh boy they got it
okay i've been to austin florida's
moving into patriot spot number one you
can't
it's just numbers folks
[Applause]
i gotta apologize to my friends in texas
but like
it's like the people's republic of
austin over there now it's like as bad
as new york maybe worse
so i want to thank you for that
dedication because it's going to take
people like yourselves
your involvement your passion to get
over the hurdles that we will always
face
we're not in a fair fight you got a
trillion dollar mainstream media
organization
doing what they can to suppress you
right how many of you guys have been
suppressed on social media
oh yeah everybody has all those problems
um we are moments from hearing from
donald trump
and uh i welcome to everybody we have
surpassed
10 000 viewers on youtube uh certain
things
are happening on twitch on facebook i
want to say thanks to tamp
st 91 as well as blue moon maiden
oscar pwns it's synergy
uh and kachna for the
twitch prime subscriptions there has
never been a better day to re-up your
twitch prime sub
and you should the website can barely
keep up with the new memberships we have
a coupon code today
sad trump because this is also it's such
a sad family
ashonda lewis has taken advantage of it
sylvain
viancourt yani kinunen
edith oh no i'm not gonna fall for that
one
not gonna fall for that one edith you
almost got me uh viviana medell
as well as winnie ball sue sheridan
as well as joe collins have signed up
finley craig and bart rainey
uh amy k and brenda landers just
really really great people all over the
place uh
signing up and just doing doing crazy
things and that uh that code is good
through the end of the night
trump speaking momentarily don jr
seemingly having a medical event during
the uh during the speech and we will go
back to him second amendment
but i do it because i believe in those
freedoms i do it because i want my
children to experience those freedoms
so we need all of you to be out there
fighting with us
so on america's birthday i want to thank
each and every one of you incredible
patriots
for doing what you do for showing the
love that you do
for not leaving in a ridiculous monsoon
[Applause]
okay
because you love your country like our
love
our country china stay in the fight
stay engaged and god bless america
happy fourth of july everyone
happy fourth of july
i look forward to hearing the big guy
come out and this big guy doesn't get
the ten percent the other one does right
thank you guys god bless
so a really powerful and coherent speech
from don jr touching on all of the
issues of the day
really convincing us that the
republican party has a plan for america
and the path forward and is issue
oriented and is ready to lead and to
improve
people's lives in a tangible oh what am
i talking about
what am i talking about um super chats
continue to come in
and people significantly triggered
by what we are seeing and i understand
it i understand it
i want to say thank you to in your
groove
for signing up via twitch prime
as i've said before make sure if you
have an amazon prime subscription
that you're signing up for something on
twitch every month it doesn't have to be
for me
right but otherwise you're just leaving
the money in jeff bezos pocket
and that doesn't sound that doesn't
sound like the way to go i want to say
thank you to ty
eckeland as well as
scott mata both of whom just signed up
on my website with today's special
coupon code
sad trump looks like newsmax is going to
a break let's see what's happening there
also president trump is on rumble make
sure you also download the rsbn
app because we are circumventing
silicon valley censorship notice that
it's not silicon
there's they're doing silicone they will
have absolutely no
silicone at any right side broadcasting
network event
they simply will not stand for it
it's just not gonna happen silica they
are completely
they they are on the saleen bandwagon
they will not do
any of the silicone stuff that's just
not they just don't do it that way okay
all right let's get back to we were
listening to
a young lady's voicemails let's get to
the second one
okay chapter 17 of revelation
here's proof that if you know anything
about the catholic church and
the recent turnover for power well not
recent i mean he's been up there for
like
eight years but here is the mind which
has wisdom the seven heads are seven
mountains on which the woman sits those
mountains i believe are the seven
continents the woman
is the catholic church it is the vatican
is rome
there are also seven kings five have
fallen
one is and that was written so i'm going
to skip to the end just to show you that
these folks are using up the full
capacity they're using the full three
minutes and then calling back
okay so this one gets cut off credit
card terminals and things of that sort
right so
and there are already microchips in the
cards the cards are not the problem
but um microchipping the hand and they
had their
people being microchipped in
scandinavian countries with
okay so that got cut off so she calls
right back okay and um
if you want not to get the number of the
beast if you care there's a chapter and
i think it's chapter nine for those who
have
the victory over the number of the beast
the mark now let me say something
serious for a second
you know when i play voicemails like
this people say these people are merely
mentally ill
it's just mental illness that's all that
it is um
this whether that's what it is or not
the u.s is filled with this crap i i
have a dozen regular callers who call in
with all of this mark of the beast
revelation
stuff um we it's it's fine to say it's
mental illness
but it's the exact same sort of
religious nuttery uh so that so so it's
more than just mental illness
beast and his image and i don't know
what the image is i think it's going to
be
eight popes or something or maybe even a
video
or a robot or something weird i don't
know he hasn't told us what it is yet
and
you probably don't even have to be in
contact with it just people who
so this one also went the full two to
three minutes the devil is in milwaukee
his name is kevin coke
and isn't it funny his last name is coke
with like the koch brothers
and then um uh donald trump was death
and mike pence's hades
uh in the sixth chapter of revelation
okay cut off calls back immediately
okay and donald trump was ilsa coke
she was known as the [ __ ] of book
involved she worked it she she
she was a woman overseer she was married
to the overseer of
uh the camp book involved all right
anyway and then there was just one more
just to close the loop on it okay now
the fox news thing and a lot of people
out there like
the republicans i mean don't you know
the reason they pick up the issues
of like homosexuality sanctity of
marriage
and all that you know picking on
homosexuals was a part of the nazi
movement
and you talk about the ladies and people
on um fox's their former nazis they're
nazis
they're nazis at a far right all right
so that's that
um it's it's just crazy um
let's just we'll we'll go to the next
one
here we go yes mr david pakman i was
wondering if you can do a show on the
entirety
of the star spangled banner or the
so-called the national anthem
the whole uh verse the whole standard
not the one that they took out the whole
thing
uh i really appreciate it thank you so
much okay
um yeah here's another one
hi david i got a comment about the
steven crowder
sam cedar event that happened so i was
really disappointed to hear
that stephen crowder does all of his
shows with his father
um presumably he travels to his with his
father when he does those campus things
i i'm not sure
but okay so not really usable
for the show um all right we'll
we'll listen to another one hi david
jason just saw your video on
just way too low of a volume level we'll
try one more
uh here we go
hey david probably uh this kid from
chicago probably a rhetorical question
but
um with uh regarding the shelvin
conviction do you think that without all
of the protests and
the football players taking the
nfl games do you think shoving would
have ever gotten
even convicted um let alone sentence
today
so just i don't know i don't know about
that
um you guys want to try one more i think
here's one in spanish
i just realized that no it's not spanish
it's so incoherent
the the text the the speech to text
thought it was spanish
but it's not muslims uh introduce
slavery into india so
muslims like enslaved people
okay oh and it also says like the
um spanish and slave the natives here
and also
um
uh yeah so the muslims
in south india and then
[Music]
and then uh brazil has like a icy
relationship with this seems um
seems like ambien
man i don't know i'm getting a little
depressed by it let's let's get away
from it it's just
oh this is why it's tough you know i
spend an hour
looking through the voicemail listening
to the voicemails and it's like
really hard to find something usable i
want to say thank you to zzdog
finn's fan as well as tool with about 20
o's
jimmy lambert
overscored aj4au
all of whom just re-upped their twitch
subs putting us
at 89. also uh
tron and devop barr
have signed up putting us at 91 because
it is a really sad
trump event you can not only can you
you should sign up on my website using
the coupon code
sad trump three people just did that
nathan quimby
just signed up caden lewis just signed
up
and tim johnson signing up numbers 92
93 and 94. very much appreciate that
we are presumably just moments from
hearing from donald trump
oh also thanks to drifter for the twitch
prime sub
you know what we'll do uh if and when we
get to
100 new member number 100
will get a free item or item from
the david pakman show store t-shirt hat
mug um really whatever you want
okay let me go through a few super chats
because i've been neglecting them
shane says thanks man for all you do
um abe says is it fair to say at this
point that russia has invaded us and is
attacking us from within
no i i don't know that that's what i
would say
you'd have to say a little more about it
teresa says sad love y'all but gotta go
smoke is coming out of my ears i
understand that
soldier says david please do a clip
soldier showing
the audience balancing going on behind
don jr pretty funny
yeah they're moving people around and
trying to put them in the right
spots it's it's pretty pathetic
not surprised that in a crowd of
thousands of overweight
sedentary elderly folks in 100 degree
weather
someone would have a medical episode
yeah true
daniel says this is like an amalgam of
an angry political speech whiny airing
of grievances and third-rate stand-up
that that's a good summary pym
tool says believe it or not junior is
fluent in farsi and hungarian
that i don't believe that i struggle to
believe
kimberly guilfoyle seemed low energy
today
right yeah it wasn't um let's see if we
can
find that high energy uh guilfoyle
best is yet to come
this was her when she had a manic
episode let's see if we can find it
in chief he always puts oh wait no uh
cpac
the best is yet
anyway
for uh and liberty and the american
dream
the best is yet to come
yeah so that was that that was that
oh earlier with prep about america first
we sold our country out
over the last 25 30 years and even
before that
and we're who's screaming in the
background to take care of our country
we owe 30 trillion dollars and things
are happening oh that's guilfoyle
i thought i thought some heckler had
gotten in and was that this is during
the guilfoyle event that is that is
something else we have so much and we
rebuilt our military so now we have a
beautiful rebuilt military
i hope we don't squander it um in terms
of the military when i was just talking
to congressman waltz
because he was in afghanistan they
pulled the troops out of afghanistan
bagram air base has been cleared out as
of this weekend
does that concern you now that biden is
it was trump's idea administration
well we had it done and i think it would
have been very smooth i pulled him out i
made it so that nobody could have
stopped it
trump didn't pull him out that's the
thing this is just continuing they're
getting pulled out now
trump's trump now is like no no very bad
idea now fend for themselves and
hopefully they'll do well but i said
we're getting we're coming back home you
know they call them the endless wars
uh i hope he does well i hope terrible
audio by the way
speaking of endless wars what do you
think about the gop leadership right now
and the changes that need to be made
well mitch mcconnell is very weak uh if
he would have
gone over the election numbers when they
were presented to him and i wish they
weren't presented they should have been
sent back to the legislatures because so
much fraud
couldn't do a thing about it dude you
lost you lost big mitch mcconnell if he
would have fought
you might have a whole different system
right now you might be in a much better
position as
our country you look at what's happening
with china you look at the disrespect
that china
look at the disrespect they have for us
they're in election
and look at what they said yesterday the
words and the
the fury and the fight we didn't have
that lack of investigation into the
wuhan labs
and the origins of the coronavirus well
the lack of investigations into that and
many things and if you look
why can't they pronounce anything
correctly the chronovirus
okay but just can they not say anything
right
very scary and the economy
with inflation i've seen inflation
before i've seen it
rear its very ugly head and it's not a
pretty picture
do you think inflation is going to be
transitory which is the word they're
using or is it here to stay for a while
no i think it's going to i think it's
going to it's not transitory that i can
tell you i don't think so look
when i left it was a dollar eighty seven
a gallon for
oil yeah cause no one was driving
anywhere and that was already up a whole
i mean this this is great and it wasn't
oil it was for gas and it just
oil is priced in barrels everything he
says just makes no sense
i know it's a very bad situation very
very dangerous very bad
it does seem like the administration
just came and immediately tried to
reverse
anything that you did sort of like you
did with obama sir stone pipeline
without asking people what the
repercussions would be or having a plan
well they even wanted to reverse a space
force so important you know i'm very
proud of that
not in 75 years has anything like that
happen last was the air force and
they wanted to do that and they were met
head-on by very
powerful people that said you're not
going to do that no they tried to
reverse a lot
some of it is irreversible and some of
it they're reversing and
it's a big mistake how do you handle it
when you sit back and you watch
a lot of the things that you said were
true and that would happen
now being determined what a tough
interview huh you know when we talk
about
vaccines and the wuhan lab and where the
china virus came from
well you know they do something called
disinformation now i'm understanding
they're saying no no
they wanted to fund the police okay it
was the republicans that wanted to
defund the police
it's called disinformation they say if
you say it enough
maybe people will believe it they did it
with russia russia russia
they did it with the ukraine hoax they
did it with impeachment
uh they did it with a lot of things i
mean they they get onto a thing they say
they just keep repeating a lie lie lie
and they hope people
believe them and now trying their best
to do it with the trump organization and
your cfo
oh they're absolutely doing that's a
disgrace and you look at all of the
things that they don't want to go you
look at hillary clinton you look at joe
biden you look at
the sun hunter but look at joe but they
don't want to and
and you know what it's just so unfair
and so bad for the country the good news
is you see the crowds
the people get it let's end on a
positive note and talk about the rally
happening today on july 4th weekend
how important she's off her own mic
until july 4th which they would like
very much to do as you know that
no i think it's very important it's very
exciting when you see the people when
you see the love you know there's great
love this is not just like
a rally these things are amazing they
say the greatest show on earth and i
think they really are and the people
make it that way we're going to do it
throughout the summer we'll do some more
we're doing one in i guess georgia i
just heard we're doing one in alabama
we're doing one uh
carolina my home state yes we're doing
one in north carolina i love north
carolina how good is north carolina no
problem we won our election
right it was beautiful and it's a great
state now we have a lot of great states
and finally not all 50 but there are
there are pretty
you know number of good states dealing
with the condo collapse in surfside
florida i know that you spoke with
governor desantis
you agreed with his decision not to come
here to who
who cares if he agrees they're talking
to him like he's still the president and
many of them believe they are
very good he should be there i told him
i said you should stay there this is not
that important
for you he of all people should be there
well i know that you care about people i
know you care about all people
oh yeah deeply and i know that that
crowd out there wants to get you on
stage so i'll let you go
thank you very much thank you so much
for joining us i really appreciate it
wow incisive and very powerful interview
really getting all the hard-hitting
issues
um and we should be just moments from
donald trump let's listen
well today and i'm holding the left
accountable to that you said it was
trump's fault it's biden's fault guess
what
we still got skyrocketing crime in these
liberal cities
is there any talking point they have
it's all that makes any sense it's it's
wild
uh okay thank you to starlet violets
jordan haddock primal assault as well as
cookster sheldon black
signing up via twitch toil420
just gifted 10 subs our good friend
deeper shades of house just re-upped
sergeant johnson reupped drifter as well
that is 16. okay hold on 95 plus 16.
five plus six is eleven one carry the
one
i think that's 111. i think that's 111.
um and we are uh oh
looks like trump is out but now the
whole video is frozen let's refresh
[Music]
and they're doing the stupid song too
okay let's see if i can thank everybody
who signed up on my website before trump
speaks
nicolas sanchez signing up with the
coupon code sad
trump oh god no i i really don't want to
mess this up
arun kumar rajagopa raja
vrajagapalan rajagapalan oh my god
arun kumar signing up with the coupon
code sad
trump i apologize sean brown is a new
member
kyle goodrich has signed up with the
code scott peltoma
as well as blake daniel or new members
nehemiah lugo chevrez is a new member
as well as alice herman putting us at
119.
very much appreciate that and uh
the code the code works my friends
quiet hey thank you we will be hearing
from
donald trump momentarily uh
and no no question uh no no idea how
long this might go
oh also thanks to the portland report
red team go and bit 101
for uh signing up via twitch
[Music]
[Applause]
uh oh okay here we've got a better feed
i think
[Applause]
[Music]
blacks for trump highly engaged they
seem thrilled to be there
everybody saluting very very thrilled to
be there
you might remember at last saturday's
event people started walking out early
they were bored
and we will be tracking that very
closely
we will be tracking slurring we will be
tracking we will really be tracking
everything i mean i don't even
i don't know it's just we've got to
track it all we will continue to have
super chats up on screen
throughout the event uh will trump ask
for the cameras to be turned around does
anybody know
that's a lot of people thank you
[Applause]
and i'm thrilled to be home in the great
state of florida with the thousands
and thousands of proud american patriots
who
stand strong for faith and family and
god and country
and never forget free and fair
elections and strong borders
i will build a great let me begin by
wishing you on our southern border and i
will have
mexico for that mark my words
and also please may we have a moment of
silence for the victims and families of
the
horrible building collapse in southside
florida thank you
trump observing a moment of silence
people just screaming stuff during the
moment of silence very much on brand
did he point to god what was that who
did he point to there
terrible terrible tragedy that's weird
seems fake
tomorrow we will celebrate 245 years of
glorious american
independence and it will not be
cancelled by the way
it will be canceled and we will teach
young people across the
country the george washington abraham
lincoln
thomas jefferson john adams benjamin
franklin
john hancock will forever
be american heroes
people want to take their names off
buildings can you believe it they took
names off buildings like george
washington
and i told you this is where they're
coming from we're not going to let that
happen they will never
be purged from history or canceled from
our hearts
the mission for all of us here tonight
is to preserve the legacy of july 4th
1772
[Music]
and to defend our liberty from the
radical left movement that seeks to
cancel this date demolish our heritage
and destroy our beloved nation
in just five months the biden
administration has launched
an all-out assault on everything we
cherish
and we value under joe biden and the
left
i don't know if it's joe to be honest
with you
it's somebody does anybody know who it
is
[Applause]
everyone's yelling kamala they still
can't say her name correctly
or they've refused to before religious
liberty is being crushed nobody took
care of religious liberty like we did
dissenters are being persecuted our
streets are being overtaken by
vicious thugs and bloodthirsty criminals
democrat cities
our border is being erased before our
very eyes it was never stronger than the
border that we
created just a few months ago critical
race theory is being shoved down
our children's throats and into the
ranks of our military
[Music]
and our generals are even going for it
maybe they're just doing that because
they think that's politics
they ought to focus on china and russia
and other things of
far greater importance big tech
monopolies are out of control
men are allowed to play in women's
sports
[Music]
so unfair so crazy and so bad for
women's and the whole women's sports
movement
so unfair so bad it'll end it'll end
it'll end hopefully sooner rather than
later and our leaders
are weakly bowing down to russia iran
and communist china there's only one way
to save our nation we have to work
harder than ever
before to win the colossal victory for
america first republicans
in the midterms next year and we have to
keep fighting exactly like we are
for right now
and i'll be doing exactly that and we
need your help
we need the help of this great country
and i just left ohio a few days ago we
had 42 000
people also no way and this crowd
they say we lost you had like this
massive storm
they say we lost nobody
[Applause]
people were leaving people were just
walking out
[Applause]
i love those guys back
[Applause]
together we will take back the house we
will take back the senate
and we will take back america we're not
going to let this happen
be great if somebody said you know why
do we need you to take those things back
you lost all of those things for us
[ __ ] of american sovereignty firsthand
you saw that
what a demolition it was the biden
administration's
willful and deliberate obliteration of
america's borders
and immigration laws is a crime against
this nation we will not stop and we will
not rest until illegal policies
are overturned and there's so many of
them they work
so quickly under my administration we
stood up
to the open borders lobby and it is a
big and powerful lobby and nobody knows
why
how the hell is this good for our
country people coming in
they're releasing them from prisons
they're criminals at the highest level
murderers drug dealers we took on the
corrupt special interests we fought the
radical globalists left and we won
one one we won so globalist again they
lost everything remember lost 18
the house 20 senate and white house
when i left office we had the most
secure border in u.s
history we ended catch and release
we ended asylum fraud we stopped the
migrant
caravans you know the caravans there's
coming back
they're coming back like never before we
deported criminal aliens
by the tens of thousands we achieved a
95
reduction in illegal border
crossings and we built nearly 500 miles
of border wall
really big powerful strong
wasn't it 88 miles
would have been nice if they finished
the border walking they got to paint the
border wall too
we needed another couple of months it
would have been complete it took us two
and a half
years of litigation we were sued by the
democrats we were sued by
schumer pelosi the democrats two and a
half years we won 11
lawsuits and we started almost
500 miles incredible but they got to
finish it up
just finish it up little sections left
yep
he got 88 miles done if he had just had
a few more months he would have gotten
all 2 000 miles done that makes a lot of
sense
but now joe biden has intentionally
dismantled the border
and allowed the cartels coyotes child
smugglers woman smugglers the biggest
smugglers they're the women smugglers
drug dealers murderers and savage
ms-13 gang members to infiltrate
our country like never before it's never
been like this
think of it six months ago we had the
safest border in history
now we have the worst and most unsafe
border in history but we are helping
other countries because their prisons
are very soon going to be totally empty
thank you very much
they're sending them into our country
they're saying we don't want these
people
they're sending them into our country
biden terminated
remain in mexico how good was that you
can't come in you have to be in mexico
they were taking everybody he ripped up
our safe third agreements with central
america you know we had agreements with
other countries they didn't want to take
back
prisoners they didn't want to take back
ms-13
criminals at the worst kind murderers
and i said well why aren't they taken
aback they didn't do it during
usually the crowd doesn't get bored
until about 35 minutes in he's already
lost the crowd it's it's actually
i've never seen him lose the crowd so
quickly it's loaded up
with ms-13 gang members and you've heard
me say this
i said to our people really that's
terrible how much
do we pay them sir we pay them
500 million dollars a year
i said that's okay stop payment and i
stopped payment
i stopped payment and the next day i got
a call
from head of honduras guatemala the el
salvador
and they said sir you stopped payment on
the money that the united states was
in brackets stupidly sending us you
stopped payments or why
sir i said because you're not taking
back people that should be in your
country
you're forcing them into ours and you're
not letting us bring them back
and we're not going to pay you ever
again we're not giving you anything they
said but sir there must be a
misunderstanding
we would love to have ms-13 back please
please send that so the following day
they all went back and we sent them back
by the thousands
and they reversed that and they reversed
our asylum reforms and they halted the
border wall and they shut down ice
this guy seems extra great patriots of
ice and
instituted catch and release
nationwide and you know what that is you
catch someone
a criminal a murderer you take the name
they don't have much of an address
and you release them into our country
congratulations
you've got a nice murderer now guys by
the thousands
in just five months the biden
administration is you guys notice that
these two ladies
that they looked over they're like well
that guy's leaving already that's weird
illegal immigration is up nearly one
thousand percent from when i was
president
and at this time in 2020
think of it there has never been
anything like the border that we created
and people could come into our country
everybody now is distracted by something
off in this direction you guys notice
that everybody's looking off in this
direction
really weird migrant alien youth are up
nearly 500 percent
and they're being resettled in cities
and towns hey by
the way where are the blacks for trump
people
all of a sudden oh hold on here's one
but
weren't there five blacks for trump
people when did they disappear i didn't
even notice that that's bizarre
and the way they were treated you've
seen them they get them dropped off the
wall they drop them from a 30-foot wall
but there are many of them on suicide
watch but that's not
all american taxpayers are now being
forced to pay
for the relatives of illegal aliens
another guy
with them in the united states isn't
that nice
isn't that nice because
it's called chain migration you know
what chain migration is
somebody comes whether is killer not
killer drug dealer not
he comes here he's allowed to bring in
his mother his father his sister's
brother
his aunt his uncle his grandfather his
grandmother
he's allowed to bring in anybody he
wants
or she wants and we don't want that
and we ended it and now they're opening
it up again they're bringing people in
by the hundreds of thousands by the
millions by the way
sure you know when they report they're
up almost a thousand percent they don't
they don't know because for everyone you
catch they say five times they say
multiply times five i say multiply at
times
more than ten times wrong more than ten
times they're destroying our country
we are witnessing an illegal mass
migration
that is planned facilitated funded aided
and abetted
by the far left democrats who thanks to
a totally rigged and just oh blacks for
trump are back now
now people are distracted by something
over in this direction it's very strange
this is this looks like a duck dynasty
guy here
it is a bizarre event i mean just just
cannot make heads or tails out of it has
no borders
and if his policies are not reversed
immediately we will have
no country and you know i watch every
once in a while some of our great
people in congress who are here we have
a lot of great people here tonight
and we're going to introduce some of
them and we have great representatives
but i watched them say oh we have to
immediately go back to the trump policy
not that easy like you got to make a new
deal with these countries you got to
make new deals with mexico i have a
great relationship
with the president of mexico what do you
do you're not the president he's talking
like he's still making deals and talking
to world leaders
you guys see how distracted the crowd is
now looking off to their right
28 000 soldiers to protect our border
free i got him for nothing
but i promise not to put tariffs on his
cars but that's okay
you know they sold 32 of our automobile
manufacturing business over a 30-year
period i'd say that's a lot
but he's terrific and we got along great
he did a great job and
one of the reasons we brought it down so
low and he doesn't want people coming
from all over the world
traipsing through mexico and by the way
they come from the middle east
they come from lots of places you don't
want to know about it tonight
i want to speak to every border agent
ice officer
and law enforcement professional who joe
biden has cruelly betrayed he's betrayed
they lied during the campaign i told you
they were lying but
a lot of people didn't believe me they
lied like hell did they lie about
energy remember we want energy they're
closing down everything
you will not be anywhere trump said
there'd be no indoor heating or cooling
no uh water or water coming out of uh
the shower you'd have to flush toilets
10 to 15 times but biden's the one
that's lying what
sure we didn't need anybody in two weeks
in two weeks you will not be energy
independent they're canceling leases
they're stopping drilling they want to
go to windmills right
windmill wind wind
oh boy oh boy they want to go let's go
build a windmill alice
and if the wind isn't blowing don't
worry about it darling we'll have to
learn to live a different way
i think it's so sad you know i'm not
against a lot of things but when i see
these big towers
these big wind towers that are rotting
and rusting and they make a lot of noise
and they drive down the value of your
homes if you happen to be in
earshot or site and it's very
intermittent energy it's not good and
they're ruining our fields
they're ruining our oceans right and
they're all made in china
and they're all made in germany germany
and china make a hundred percent of
those
big wind towers so they got to be
laughing at us
it's so sad you saw what happened in
texas they froze up got a little cold
they froze up
i think uh texas you have a great
governor in tech
yeah as many of you guys know that's
completely untrue
i have an entire uh youtube clip about
the truth about what happened in texas
and it's very much different than what
donald trump is telling you to know that
the american people thank you
they believe in you they love you they
respect you
they need you oh there's kids i just
know look at this there's one kid here
and another kid here
is this in a sense it could be child
abuse right i mean is this child abuse
backstage i'll tell you these are these
are great people
we are going to elect a republican
congress to terminate joe biden's open
border catastrophe
defund his extreme agenda and give our
ice and border patrol the resources
support
and gratitude they so richly deserve
the socialist democrats have not only
brought chaos and bedlam to the border
they brought every bad thing you can
have to this border this border is
a disaster by defunding police
about and by the way do you hear the new
one
it was the republicans you know what
they do it's called disinformation like
russia russia russia
trump was so friendly with russia trump
worked for russia you know they say it
over and
over on the fake news media oh there's a
lot of them back
oh there's three kids here one two three
oh boy all wearing a table though
trump loves russia you know i'm the one
that exposed the pipeline i shut down
the pipeline to europe i don't think
they like me too much
but you know they say it over and over
and so now they're getting killed by the
defunder police which they're doing by
the way
but they're getting absolutely killed so
all of a sudden they said today i heard
and
there's a word disinformation it's
called this if you say it
enough keep saying it just keep saying
they'll start to believe you we can't
let that happen because now they're
saying
the republicans wanted to to fund the
police i said
you know i heard it for the first time i
said you know
did i hear that wrong please uh play
that over again
you know nowadays we can actually play
things over again
i said play it over again it was the
republicans fault
it is such a disaster what these people
do it's disinformation
they say it again and again and again
and
after months and months of hearing it
and we have no free press anymore the
free press is
truly gone other than a few sources it's
gone
so they get away with this stuff we
cannot let it happen
we have to be much tougher stronger and
smarter
we have to be by defunding police
abolishing cash bail and releasing
tens and tens and tens of thousands of
dangerous criminals from jail
the radical left is bringing a nightmare
of mayhem
and lawlessness to every city every
suburb and every community in america
you know when
when they come in through these jails
they don't stay there they go
all throughout your beautiful community
that includes florida
and ohio and iowa and every other state
in the union
joe biden canceled our program to send
federal law enforcement to cities
overrun by
violent crime isn't it interesting to
know that every one of those cities is
democrat
leaving innocent americans at the mercy
of brutal gangsters and ruthless
killers people are afraid to go into
those cities
now the murder rate has just seen its
largest single year
increase in history all in democrat
runs cities and areas think of that now
how did they recover from that
look at chicago such a great city and
now look at what's happened
look at new york the prosecutors never
want to talk about anybody that murdered
they don't want to talk about anybody
that's trafficking in drugs they're
letting the people out
by the thousands the bloodshed is beyond
belief
this week a 21 year old u.s marine
was hit by a stray bullet in broad
daylight
while standing in the middle of times
square
78 people were shot in chicago last week
in london now
just think of that they were shocked 78
people you know people are sort of
thinking about other things maybe you're
not having a great time is everybody
having a great time tonight
he's suffering the subject is a negative
one eventually the subject will be the
most positive one you've ever be
involved in okay
now these rallies are incredible thanks
to amanda pancake for signing up on my
website with the code
sad trump and it is sad isn't it this
area is
so great
we won florida by a lot we won florida
by a lot
a lot
[Applause]
oh he's here
[Music]
so you know i live in florida i'm a
citizen of florida listen to this
it's called the resident i was down here
thank you very much but
the president just said he's a citizen
of a state guys
guys after commercial i think they spent
240 million dollars in florida
one lightweight put up a hundred million
dollars
of negative ads i don't know he was
jealous because he did so poorly in a
debate
something happened put up a hundred
million
they spent hundreds of millions i turned
on every commercial was a kill i called
my people i said
how the hell can i win florida they said
sir you're going to win in a landslide
and that's what happened that's what
happened
it's pretty amazing because ultimately
the people are really smart they don't
get enough credit
if you want law and owner and justice
you have only that's actually great the
former
president doesn't realize the difference
between
residency and citizenship
that's that's strange we have some good
results
america first save america but there's
something about magga
just keeps coming back right mega
mega country even while the democrat
extremists
let murderers rapists drug dealers and
dangerous criminals run wild in democrat
cities
they're corrupting and weaponizing the
law against their political opponents
oh gee i'm so surprised radical left new
york city and state prosecutors
who have allowed crime to skyrocket to
we have never seen anything like what's
happened that was a glitch
record levels record murders up
a percentage that's not even possible
and outrageously and shamefully
continuing the greatest witch hunt
that's what they do they go and target
me
they target i've been targeted since i
came down the escalator do you remember
a muller the 18 angry democrats remember
that
remember when i came down and said that
thing about mexican rapists ever since
that day they've been going after me
there was no collusion i couldn't
believe they came up with that
friend of mine said you have to be the
cleanest guy in history
think of it two and a half years
48 million the mueller report no
collusion
this is the kind of persecution that
they're doing as an example in new york
and they're doing it all over
that you would see in a third world
nation this isn't for us
it's reminiscent of a communist
dictatorship targeting your political
opponents for
really it is it is uh think of it
prosecution they prosecute people good
people fabulous people
people that love our country honest
people fabricating charges to try and
silence them
abusing the justice system and leaking
out information on a daily basis in the
press
to engage in flagrant care people
literally sleeping at the event see this
baby asleep right here can't stay awake
it's unprecedented unheard of and
totally
unacceptable in america for prosecutors
to run for office
on a promise to get their political
enemies how about the one new york state
we're going to get trump i'm running
she's running i'm going to get trump
i promise her knows nothing about me all
she knows she's going to get me
from the day she got in i'm gonna get
trump but you know the people are wise
to it the people there they people get
it i'm gonna
get trump vote for me i don't know a
damn thing about him but i'm gonna get
him
but even if they've committed no crimes
no problems it's a fascist and
authoritarian and the people who talk
about democracy are literally destroying
it before
our very eyes nobody can believe the
things that we're witnessing so many
things
after hundreds of subpoenas and that
includes
mueller and all of the congress where i
was i have been
think of it probably no president
has done more than we have the trump
administration including him
now the crowd's alive now with the
lowest taxes the biggest tax cut ever
with
the biggest regulations these are every
single one of these things is a lie i
mean it's not you know he's not even
president so it's not worth
debunking each thing but it's the same
stuff we were debunking all of the
presidency
which everybody's big big deal lots of
big deals but
but just think of it we did all of this
and
constantly under investigation by the
radical left
from day one from the day i came down
the escalator with your great and
beautiful
future first lady
right from that day
[Applause]
they do love our first lady i'm all set
she's great
she is great and she loves you and she
says hello after
over three million pages of documentary
think of that three
million pages great company big big
company
great company they don't give you credit
for that i used to get a lot of credit
i get credit from the people that know
four years of searching dozens and
dozens of interviews and millions and
millions of dollars
spent of taxpayer funds all wasted
the radical left continues to search for
a crime
and wreck lives break laws violate every
principle of justice fairness and
liberty you see it you see it on a
constant basis
it's really called prosecutorial
misconduct whoa it's a terrible
terrible thing there is no depth
to which the radical left will not sink
to stop
our make america great again
movement think of it
new york prosecutors did not go after a
single financial firm after the 2008
financial crisis caused by all of those
firms
which devastated and almost destroyed
our country no one was ever held
accountable no one
they did not go after hunter biden or
his father
for major crimes you know joe was
totally in on it
look you know he joe said i didn't know
anything about it a report came out
today in the new york post
and actually by some great reporters new
york post has done an incredible job
but where joe biden knew everything he
knew everything
hunter biden what they did with money
pouring in from russia from ukraine
from china they didn't go after hillary
clinton and her foundation they didn't
touch her
they leave democrats alone no matter how
bad they are
but they've mobilized every power of
government
to come after me my family my wonderful
employees
and my company solely because of
politics they want to do things to hurt
us
we're too smart we're too good i think
we're too good and we're too united
because remember this
the democrats have horrible policy think
of it open borders
sanctuary cities i mean the policies are
so defund the police it's their policy
remember don't let them
talk anybody out of that what prominent
um
democratic senators want to defund the
police i'm trying to think
republicans i don't know why what
democratic senators at all forget about
prominent
back the way they fight but they do have
one thing that's good they stick
together you don't have mitt romney and
little ben sass
and these people you don't have these
people
they stick together and i respect that
the harder i fight for you the harder
they come after me
crime is rampant on our streets of these
cities
and these prosecutors refuse to
prosecute even for murder deadly assault
robbery drug and human trafficking they
refuse to
prosecute the only one they want to
prosecute is me or republicans
right how many of the congress people
are under investigation over there
they're letting thousands and thousands
of criminals out of jail you said it was
just announced they're letting all these
people
he seems to be just redoing the same
material
i don't mean from previous rallies
obviously it's all from previous rallies
he seems to be doing the same stuff from
15 minutes ago we're afraid to go to our
democrat
run cities i don't like going they're
afraid to go
who the hell wants to go and yet they go
after good hard-working people more
people bail we're not paying taxes on a
company car
company you didn't pay tax on the car
or a company apartment you used an
apartment because this woman's talking
into her phone here
her watch here it says you didn't pay
tax
or education for your grandchildren
i don't even know do you have to but
does anybody know the answer to that
stuff
okay but they indict people for that
isn't trump's entire fortune or at least
the basis of it
based on doing business in the very city
new york city that he claims is terrible
for business
nothing right that's okay
think of it think of how unfair it is
never before
has new york city and their prosecutors
or perhaps any prosecutors criminally
charged a company or a person
for fringe benefits fringe benefits
murder's okay human trafficking no
problem but fringe benefits you can't do
that
every abuse and by the way every company
and everybody
who the hell that people don't even know
they don't even know every abuse
and attack they throw my way is solely
because
i have been fighting for you against the
corrupt establishment
be interesting to interview people as
they leave and say hey what did you
learn today that you didn't know when
you walked in here i think that would
lead to some pretty interesting
clips investigations they've all seen
this mueller he spent 48 million dollars
he saw it they also had many people they
saw it
but this last group the radical left
they said listen we failed in washington
to get them
here's the papers see if you can take
them out new york
radical left new york it's because i
have called for their
and i called them out on the lies and
exposed their incompetence and taken
away their power and perhaps
most importantly it's because i got
we got i got 75
million votes remember he got 74 million
just like the flu was 1918.
uh but it doesn't matter if the other
person gets seven eight million more
but that's by far the most of any
sitting president in history
thank you and biden's 81.2 million
is the most of anybody ever
well trump uh oh my god look at this
guy's saluting oh my god isn't that
so is the i think the concept there is
that trump's still the commander did you
guys see this guy stand up and salute
a big thank you to judy lilly for
signing up we have a coupon code sad
trump it's active right now
of any sitting president
in the history of our country far more
than obama far more than anybody
and again how many more would we have
gotten
starting to slow elections
how many i can tell you i think many
millions and millions but a lot of
things are happening watch
just stay tuned i want to uh thank so
many of the states you look at what's
going on in some of the states it's
incredible what they're doing because
they get it
and i'm far more popular now than on
election day because the people have
watched what the hell has happened to
our country in just
that's not true a very short period of
time
if anything people have forgotten how
horribly he dealt with kovid if
if it's even true that his approval is
up it's really an atrocious
abuse of power nobody's ever seen
anything like this and the american
people
will not stand for it i know that
[Applause]
now we're thrilled to be joined tonight
by many outstanding republican leaders
uh-oh and they're really friends of mine
and they're warriors and there are a few
here that i'm not going to introduce
because they're not warriors so the hell
with them who cares
all right they're not warriors kind of
me
they're not warriors but these people
are incredible and these are the kind of
people we need and these are the people
that made our country great
these are will he will he introduce
gates who he's been trying to distance
himself from
for possible child sex trafficking
representative
greg stubey stand up frank
vern buchanan vern thank you
thank you very much a very shy man
mike waltz thank you mike
thank you great job you're doing mike
somebody with an unbelievable future i
wish i had his future
i want his future byron donalds
i've not heard of most of these people
right away right
i gave him an endorsement i met him i
said i'm endorsing him it took about 12
minutes
a friend of mine a great guy he's
fighting fighting fighting
and is it gates i guess they don't like
people that do that
but he's somebody who's very special in
so many ways
and he's a very brave guy matt gates wow
remember that they've been while
standing ovation for days
trump had been distancing from gates for
a while because it looked so bad
and now trump actually going fully in
wow
another warrior and somebody that really
loves this state
you know who it is no
you know who it is right gus bilirakis
gus belarakis he's uh never heard of
somebody that fights like hell where is
he
gus thank you gus
scott franklin you know scott
thanks scott
and a woman who's become a friend of
mine she's incredible and i guarantee
you nobody's going into her house
unless they have approval there was no
games right
he's screaming out lauren it's lauren
lauren or bobert oh
god wow
nobody's going into your house suddenly
blacks for trump are engaged they like
beau bird i guess
and also the guy with the neck beard
loved it thanks lord
vice chair of the florida gop christian
ziegler christian thank you
great job great job on the election
my son don who got up and made a speech
did he do a good job
did he do that yeah people love don he's
a great guy and
kimberly guilfoyle i listened to their
speeches they work right
and i just want to thank all of them and
others that are here and
you know we have a lot of people from
our republican party they fought like
hell in this election against a lot of
arts because the money that was spent is
unprecedented and
you are fake a lot by a record
and i just want to thank them all and uh
the people from congress and the people
from the republican party
uh what a job you did and thank you very
much i really hope he brings up that guy
chris calamari or whatever his name is
i want to thank a group it's called
right side broadcasting network
[Music]
of our incredible movement oh no
standing ovation for right side
broadcasting you know they got banned
because they held a speech or something
and they got banned
from where they got banned
and they don't give a damn they're out
there they're fighters they have been so
great
and oen and newsmax and a lot of
a lot of great people a lot of guys
we're getting the word out like never
before it's been amazing this is all
live stuff and a lot of cameras are
going right now that's good thank you
very much i don't want to mention bad
about anybody because they'll turn those
cameras off immediately
and i also want to thank a man who is a
true fighter you do not want to fight
with them these are tough guys but don't
fight with this guy
jorge massa vidal because he brought
miami to a level that nobody thought a
republican could get to
and jorge i want to thank you very much
you are
really he i mean listen i get that the
trump's not great with languages but
couldn't we do a little bit better than
jorge
we can't do any better than that go to
sky king
fireworks and you know
you know sky king said we are big fans
and we want to do a great show
so i'll let you know if it's any good
because right after i'm finished we're
going to have the best fireworks you've
ever seen
i'm staying i'm smashed yes everybody
loves tyler
[Applause]
and the sarasota republican party led by
my good friend
florida republican party chairman joe
grunders
for tonight's fireworks show where's joe
i love joe
joe gave me the man of the year before i
ever did this he gave me man of the year
twice
that's why he gave it to me once and
then he gave it to me during romney's
convention because he probably knew
where romney was going and that wasn't
to a victory
yeah but it was during the convention
and he i said you know i have a little
conflict i have the convention
he said i'll take the award i came i
came to sarasota i think that night or
the night before
and joe has done a fantastic job thank
you very much joe appreciate it
and other people that have been
incredible and my people came up they
said please sir would you do us a favor
what
would you thank the sarasota police and
fire departments for the incredible job
and i said yes i will
[Applause]
yes i will and they said sir also please
sir
sarasota county sheriff's office and all
of law enforcement here tonight from all
over florida
we thank you we love you and we
appreciate it thank you very much
i'm really interested in this guy's
story right here the guy who stood up
and saluted trump and who's in uniform i
want to know more about it incredible
tonight
you know we had a lot of people came
into this area and they came in quickly
and with you came the storms and then
you sat
and you got drenched is everybody
drenched
trump's soaking wet already as he likes
to sing well
you don't have to worry about taking a
shower tonight that's so clean
that water is so clean and nice he's so
funny each and every one of us here
tonight is part of a movement unlike
anything the world has
ever seen before that's true never been
a movement
that's true never been a movement like
this
you know i know people good people
they've gone into republican primaries
democrat primaries and they did you know
really well they came in second third
fourth
and they became famous for the rest of
their lives and their commentators
and they're good we won the presidency
changed the world
we gained respect all over the world for
our country again
and where do you see what's going to
happen because great
great things are going to happen for our
country
but there's never been anything like it
there's never been anything like it
[Applause]
we've already accomplished more than
anyone
thought even possible and that's despite
as i said before all of the
everyday subpoenas this subpoenas you
know congress
has set back hundreds and hundreds
every day on a daily basis we've got
subpoenas
they want to see this they want to see
that somebody said to me
very smart person one of the smartest
people
actually very successful said could i
ask you a question first of all
how do you take it i said i don't know
it almost becomes like
part of the work program how do you take
it
how the hell do you take it and they ask
me that question a lot
how do you do this but what we've done
is something that nobody thought
possible
how do you do it we do it because i love
what we've done and what we've done is
going to get
better and better and the beautiful
thing about what happened is
now people can see how bad it can go
and how quickly it can be taken away and
we can't let that happen
we can't let that i couldn't tell you
what he's talking about i really
couldn't
i don't know what he's saying
[Applause]
and to think
to think that we were all set i'll tell
you what we would have had a deal with
iran
in one week one week thank you
i love you too look at that what do you
mean we would have had a deal with iran
he had
months to make when he didn't make one
would have had a deal with iran in one
week
we had done such a great job in china
you know the story with china we made
one of the greatest trade deals ever
made but
china's the plague came in from china i
felt much to i don't even talk about it
but it's helped our farmers a lot and
our manufacturers and
and they have lived up to that deal i
will say that about china
uh but it's uh it's just a terrible
thing
and so many other things were happening
that was so positive you know north
korea president obama told me that north
korea is going to be the biggest problem
i got along with kim jong-un and i got
along with him they fell in love as he
says
and it was only a very corrupt election
that slowed us down uh-oh what's going
on
there's a big commotion but good things
are gonna happen
remember we passed record-setting tax
cuts
there's massive regulation cuts
we adopted pro-american energy policies
[Music]
oh it's so sad to say it because you're
not going to have it anymore
look at that beautiful price that you're
paying now and gasoline aren't you happy
at 3.50
you know what in a year from now you'll
be extremely happy at 350 because it's
going to go a hell of a lot higher
187 to 350 but we hadn't done american
energy independence i was so proud of
that
we fought for fair trade because every
country
in the world was ripping off the united
states the european union was almost as
bad as china but nobody wants to say
that you know it's europe
nobody wants to say nobody would say and
then we got them to pay
nato nato 430
billion dollars because they weren't
paying their bills so i said listen
you're ripping yourself on trade you
know the expression how many chevrolets
you find in the middle
of munich not too many like maybe one i
doubt it
right because it would be totally
natural for germans to say
we've got bmw we've got mercedes
we've got audi we've got volkswagen
get me a chevy let's bring let's bring
some chevy's here we need chevys
before the play came in and then when
the plague did come in the china virus
came in
we did it again we did it again and you
have a great
economy if we didn't have the strong
foundation and the radical left used to
look i mean what's funny is you know
what american cars you see in germany
you see tesla
that's what you see was india doing they
got a lot of problems
look at how well this country this
country they have suffered at a level
that nobody ever thought but all these
countries that we
and they were only doing it to try and
compare us to a country that they
thought at the time
was doing well they didn't do too well
because what india and others are going
through right now
is not even thinkable not even thinkable
and what we're doing now is we're if
they don't kill it with inflation and
all the factors because you're going to
see some things that are
happening that are very bad they're
doing some very dangerous and very bad
things
but we've never had an economy like we
had before
and we built it because the foundation
was so strong remember this
we had 160 million people working
we were never even close to that
african-american
asian american hispanic american
women women young people people with the
diploma people without a diploma
[Applause]
people from mit harvard and wharton
they did great people that didn't go to
the best schools did great
everybody was doing great and actually
i was getting calls from people on the
left
let's get together i'm telling you it
was starting i was starting to see that
there was going to be
he was three days from completely
bridging the gap with democrats
and then the virus hit we never had
better employment numbers we've
never had every group was making more
than they had ever made before
and the biggest beneficiary were blue
collar workers it was a beautiful thing
to watch
and i'm telling you had we not been hit
by the
plague this country would be very
unified
i really believe it can you believe that
and i'm never sure you know
how long has he been going but i was
getting calls from people that you would
not have believed
very friendly calls they couldn't
believe what was happening and then we
got hit
and we had to do it again and we did it
twice i guess about it twice
during the pandemic we produced three
vaccines in record time
and remember three to five years they
said
and they said but it probably won't
happen he's responsible for the vaccine
that we don't even really need because
it's not serious guys
so yeah taking it at all of that but
what a difference what a great thing
and that's for the world had we not had
that
trump must be praised for developing the
vaccine to save us from the virus that's
not serious anyway
but anything good is definitely trump's
fault we would have had another
1917 spanish flu here we go
it's 1918. there's no reason to keep
saying 17. they say
died but while joe biden now wants
credit
for all of our successes do you remember
during the inauguration he said he
created the vaccine
i said no joe biden never said that on
december 11th remember we put it into
your arm
to keep you safe joe biden never said
that his radical agenda and far left
policies have already begun to destroy
our country
biden canceled the american keystone xl
pipeline
thank goodness
[Applause]
and he approved the russian pipeline to
europe
it's not even and they say
trump wasn't tough on russia really i
stopped their pipeline
even that whole thing biden approved i
mean it's like
it's not biden's biden can't approve
that let it go through
so what's that all about trump wasn't
tough on russia and i actually had
and have a very good relationship with
president putin
but that's a good thing that's not a bad
thing that's actually a very good thing
and until the play came in i'm being
told we should be focusing in on this
guy in the blue shirt as well as his
wife
who look maybe more bored than anyone
there i'm gonna keep an eye on them for
the next
period of time and see what what they do
wife looking a little bit engaged the
guy in particular seems so bored
i wasn't going to take their nonsense
because they rip us off
at a level that you've never seen before
outside of china
and a couple of others biden re-entered
the
job-killing paris climate accord
okay that's going to cost us a trillion
dollars and you have to close a lot of
factories
it was a big mistake to do china doesn't
kick into that deal for many many years
russia kicks in at the lowest level and
we're going to pay trillions of dollars
for china
lose lots of business it's a disaster
you know one thing that happened the
world health organization so what i
pulled out of that because they blew
every conceivable thing having to do
they said
this guy is yawning he seems physically
in pain from what's going on now he's on
his phone
this may be the most bored guy that's
actually a it's a good assessment that
someone just
sent me i had a good relationship with
him honestly i had a pretty good relay
he said just call me tony sir
i call him just call me tony he said sir
just call me tony
he's a hell of a promoter though don't
you agree remember
no masks master terrible don't wear a
mess and now he's a
radical master have three masks and if
you can put on goggles and a helmet
that's kind of funny but biden's pushing
now the
largest tax hike in history i gave you
the largest tax
decrease in the history
that's what i mean about their policies
how the hell can
open borders tax increases all of these
things sanctuary cities
all of the crap they want to teach our
kids in school
how can that be good you know what if
they had good policy i think they'd be
hard to beat but their policy is so bad
it's so radical and it's so sick i'm
told there's three
larry the cable guy clones on screen i
don't know that i
see i see this guy here for sure that's
a larry the cable guy clone
maybe this guy but i don't know that i
see three structure plan
would annihilate america's suburbs by
abolishing
single-family home zoning here in
florida and nationwide
and the reason they mention that is
because i wrote all of that stuff off
you know that
i used to campaign on the suburbs then
they say
how did trump do with women in the
suburbs i think i did very well
i think you know
are people referring to this guy i mean
i don't think the age
fits i got 63 million votes
and john mclaughlin said sir if you get
64 or
65 the election is over you win because
most presidents go down
in the second term when they run obama
went way down he won the second
time you know his competition was romney
who the hell is he going to beat romney
in in one of the worst campaigns in
history it's an embarrassment
but he beat romney oh the neckbeard guy
is sort of a yeah that's that's true
he's kind of a larry the cable guy clone
he is he blocked by the teleprompter
trump doesn't use
oh no he's you get 64 million or 65
million
there is no way you can lose the
election i got
75 million and they said we lost
the usa today explained biden's deranged
socialist scheme with quote
a house with a white picket fence and a
big backyard for the 4th of july
barbecue celebration
may be a staple of the american dream
but
experts and local politicians say
multi-family zoning is the key to
combating
climate change always climate change and
remember this
climate change you only have nine years
left
right remember where aoc got up
we have 12 years but we might have
problems we better be careful about
nuclear and our
but you're not going to worry about
you're just gonna do everything right
you'll be fine but we have because of
climate change 12 years to live
they were down to now nine is anybody
nervous about it
somehow i'm not i'm not but
racial injustice and nation's growing
housing crisis and
that was the quote in other words if
biden and the radical democrats get
their way you can
kiss your suburbs your fourth of july
your barbecue
and you can kiss the american dream
goodbye you know that and by the way why
would you have to kiss barbecue goodbye
election now we are looking at the
election
but more than looking at it but you know
what there's not even an election
but if they're looking at the election
but there isn't one okay got it days ago
like ohio or wherever we go we have
tens of thousands of people show up that
means you're damn unhappy
and you're looking for hope you're
looking for hope
and you're isn't it like 2 500 people
going to destroy our country the leftist
democrats truly seem to hate our country
and really despise our way of life and
it's hard to believe that they can
you know you think about it we want good
education we want a strong military we
want borders we want
uh all the different things we want to
have
income we want so many basic things they
want income
space force is wonderful they didn't
want to have space for us
they all of these things all of these
things
it's so basic you know i actually call
it the party of common sense somebody
said are you a very strong conservative
i said you know i guess so but i'm
really a person that believes in common
sense
i don't want to have the open borders
right i don't want to have open borders
this is a trope we're not reactionary
clowns
we're just about common sense all sorts
of people
i don't want to have that i want to have
great education
i want to have a powerful powerful
military i want to have powerful and
wonderful law enforcement
they don't they wanted to fund the
police and
joe biden is perhaps the most
unpatriotic president in american
history in that sense he canceled
the fourth of july fireworks display at
mount rushmore
i am i am for canceling all fireworks i
think it's just absurd
i'm done with fireworks she came to me
christine holmes came to me sir for many
many years we haven't been able to do
fireworks at mount rushmore i said why
they say it's the environment and they
say it's dangerous i say really
is there anything that's going to catch
a fire no sir i said yeah it's all stone
right stone
stones not gonna burn and i approved it
three years ago they had some of the
most
beautiful there's almost nothing we can
do in sarasota to top it if this
fireworks company does anything close
i'll be very impressed okay
but we had fireworks at mount rushmore
that was so incredible
and it's all stone it's stone and it was
wonderful and then i saw the other day
that they refused to allow it to happen
again i think they do it in spite it's
so ridiculous
it's so sad the left wants to cancel
the heroes on mount rushmore they
actually want to
take mount rushmore you've heard this i
mean nobody's surprised they want to
take down the jefferson memorial
they probably don't want to take it down
they want to take the statue
of thomas jefferson out and replace it
with somebody
by the way let me tell you you're not
going to be happy with the person they
want to replace him with
ladies and gentlemen thomas jefferson is
being removed from the jefferson
memorial
and being replaced with the reverend al
sharpton
[Music]
i mean i i wouldn't even i don't even
think many democrats would want that
no well nobody would have a problem with
that
he's it's probably racist what he's
saying right i could name plenty that
they want to replace him with and uh not
good
it's not good not acceptable not
acceptable we stopped that
that was going to they were heading that
way and i signed the bill
if you touch it you go to jail for 10
years and everyone turned around and
they went back home
ladies and gentlemen the thomas
jefferson memorial is
now going to replace by joe biden
president biden is going to replace yes
biden will will put his own statue there
i'm sure that would happen
and honestly it was sad it was sad and i
felt badly for him i do
because i want what's good for the
country but this was a very sad
situation and
nancy was big speaking of sad we find
these trump events so sad that we uh
we've set up a coupon code
sad trump on my website joinedpakman.com
but 130 people have used it today
uh feel free and uh i will thank you sad
trump this is so sad
a lot of bad a lot of bad things were
happening with that speech and i said
that's really sad
and then i turned on msdnc and cnn i
just wanted to see what they
thought and they go uh this was one of
the
truly great speeches of our time you
know fdr
a lot of people here might not like fdr
but he was a great elegant speaker right
the only thing you have to fear is fear
itself
right remember how beautiful the words
were so beautiful
the voice was so beautiful the brain
actually worked well it was a good
breath
and one of them on cnn
[Music]
said this very much compares
to the late great fdr
they said that and that's why their
credibility has gone down the tubes
they were comparing his guys which was
sad
it was sad they were comparing it to
fdr no that doesn't work but their
credibility's at an
all-time low the media the fake news
media is at an all
did i have anything to do with that i
think so i think it's one of my greatest
achievements
i think one of my greatest achievements
is explaining to people
that the media in this country is
corrupt it's actually one of his most
dystopian authoritarian
uh achievements turning half the country
against
the institution of the media and a free
press it's actually pretty horrifying
memory just went off
two cameras just went up they don't like
it when i do
that i like to give them warnings so
they could just go to a commercialism
yeah no one's willing to buy ads on this
stuff six commission to honor america's
founding
within hours of taking office almost
immediately great people were put on
that commission great great patriots
he canceled the national garden of
american heroes it was going to the
great state of tennessee
and he announced one year ago tonight to
celebrate this was announced
about a year ago was going to tennessee
we were going to build
beautiful magnificent statues to the
greatest people in the history of our
country
he canceled it why why would you do that
it was going to tennessee
the biden white house publicly took the
side of the
olympic athlete who denounced the
national
anthem and who shunda are grateful
and a place of old-fashioned love of
america the biden administration has new
rules pushing
hateful marxist critical risks so what
is the deal with this military guy like
if he
if he's in active service it would be he
could be
discharged for appearing in uniform at
an event like this or what how does that
all work
racism it has no place in our schools in
our military or in our country
when we take back congress republicans
must
defund immediately people saying it's
not an active service uniform
okay i wouldn't know that that's
interesting
and refuse to pass any spending bill
that does not
stop these mine trainings and restore
order to our borders with joe biden and
the radical left
it is always america last it's america
last look at what he's doing it's
america last
other countries are laughing at us they
are they can't even believe it
well i was president it was always
america first and our country was
respected again
we withdrew from the horrible iran
nuclear deal
how about that beauty 150 billion
dollars 1.8 billion in cash
we wiped out isis and other radical
islamic terrorists
biden has a lot to be thankful for but
obama couldn't do it obama biden
couldn't do it
we did it we knocked out the entire
caliphate in syria and iraq
we terminated al-baghdadi and salamani
we fully rebuilt the united states
military and completely restarted
the nasa space program all these ships
you see that's because of
us it was closed ships what on earth is
he talking about like
what what is he actually referring to
right now runway nasa i went down i said
this is sad
we totally opened it up now everyone's
bidding millions of dollars to go up to
space
we created space force and we took
care of our vets ships like nobody has
ever taken care of our vests
getting a 92 approval rating the highest
in history by many many points the truth
is
more uh uh of the military voted for
biden
than typically do for democrats um
that's that's the truth gary what a job
we recognize jerusalem as the capital of
israel
recognized israeli sovereignty over the
golan heights
and we made historic peace deals in the
middle east
the abraham accords and we brought our
troops back home
they're back home most of them are back
home which one is that
we also impose historic sanctions on the
evil communist regime in china
and the brutal socialist regime in
venezuela
perhaps most importantly of all i stood
up to communist china like nobody has
ever before imposing gigantic tariffs
saving our steel industry and other
industries
if i didn't do that we wouldn't even
have a steel industry
through which they're now paying us
billions and billions of dollars and
obama wants to cancel it but you notice
they haven't done it yet it's too much
money
that's the one thing china didn't want
is tariffs
biden is weak on china just like he is
weak on
everything else except prosecuting
republicans
and now he has done nothing to hold
china responsible for unleashing the
virus
upon us and the rest of the world as you
probably noticed the democrats and the
media
are now admitting that i was right about
virtually everything all along
almost everything that is completely
untrue
the virus came from the chinese lab
remember when they said horrible when i
said it came from wuhan the lab
they went horrible they went crazy i
said what did i say
common sense right hydroxychloroquine
works untrue
they cost lives they cost lives i should
have done it differently i said
you should not take under any
circumstances
hydroxychloroquine and they would have
said horrible you must take it and i
would have been happy
but i didn't do it i should have done it
with the wall too instead of two and a
half years of litigation
we will not build a wall under any
circumstances the world would have been
built in 15 minutes
they like to go the opposite hunter
biden's laptop was real
right when he was asked a question on
a very friendly news program and
is it real um i don't know oh you don't
know if you don't know
that means it's real lafayette square
was not cleared
for a photo op right they thought it was
yeah that first came out
the russian bounty remember the russian
bounty story
was a total fake it was made up by
shifty shift
remember russia russia russia was a hoax
paid for by the dnc and crooked hillary
clinton
the mueller witch hunt showed no
collusion
this guy's totally unengaged he just
leaned over he said
kathy did i remember to pick up that
itch cream not guilty
we produced vaccines before the end of
2020. remember that they said oh
so many years don't do it we got them
done
blue state lockdowns did not work we
said
open up your states it's up to the
governors we said open up your states
schools should be opened immediately
right immediately
our border security actions were
completely necessary
and joe biden's agenda is every bit as
radical and disastrous
as i predicted i said all these things
remember in the second debate
when i talked about energy and he said
no he's against energy i said whoa
i felt like perry mason that was the
last question
right now it was the last question i
felt just like i said
did you hear that nobody could believe
it but you know what
well because it didn't happen he's
destroying the energy industry
in this country he actually that was one
of the things he told the truth on
i wonder what i will be proved right
about next
perhaps it will be the election
crowd likes that huh
so bleacher's wife is clapping but blue
shirts still will not clap even at that
[Music]
military guy saluting again not sure if
it's actually making me uncomfortable
the evidence of fraud irregularities and
illegality is already overwhelming and
frankly it was
a long time ago democrats used
covid to cheat they illegally changed
the rules in the key states
and mailed out millions and millions and
millions of
absentee ballots all over the place
people went in to vote republicans
blue shirt guys got to be thinking of
how to get out of this i haven't
i waited for this day i've been waiting
for
a year to vote you voted i'm sorry you
voted here's an absentee ballot
they didn't use them they didn't use
them they stole the votes
people walked in by the tens of
thousands to vote
and these are solid strong great people
and they said you've already voted and
three things happened
people would go crazy people would get a
little bit upset
or people would just shrug their
shoulders and just leave they'd go
yeah i'm sad this isn't funny i'm
getting sort of like um
you know like shooter vibes from a lot
of the people that are on screen behind
trump and it's
it's kind of freaking me out ballot
applications to every person on the
rolls
dead or alive legal or illegal right
they mailed out these applications they
used hundreds of millions of dollars
from
left-wing billionaires to put on lawful
drop boxes
all over democrat-run cities to scoop up
ballots
in swing states nobody's ever seen
these drop boxes they're called drop
boxes people coming in nobody knows who
the hell voted
and they came out 96 for slippy joe
biden right 96
he got 96 in some of them
i got 4 actually that's better than i
thought you know
quite a cadence to this speech really
goes sequentially from one piece to the
next
election take a look at new york watch
what's happening there but this is the
most corrupt election
they said hours is worse than what's
happening in new york will he say
massive dumps here of ballots operatives
door-to-door and democrat neighborhoods
to harvest
democrat votes by the thousands
and like in georgia deleted over a
hundred thousand voters off the voter
rolls
after the election i said why didn't you
do it before the election i lost very
close election
it wasn't close actually i won by a lot
but the loss they gave me was very close
like 11 000 votes 100 000 votes were
deleted after the election
what's going on with georgia 100 think
of it
100 more than a hundred thousand
and i just asked one simple question why
didn't you do that
if you don't mind before the election
wouldn't that be nice they abolished
signature verification requirements
created a powerful system for
media and online censorship of their
opponents and did everything possible
to facilitate fraud just like you would
do
a lot of people getting banned today by
the way that's what happened with this
election
that's why there are so many people here
tonight if we lost the election
i still would have a good crowd because
we have a good but you know what i
wouldn't have a crowd
that goes beyond what the eye can see
that stays
in a thunderstorm where they're going
ladies and gentlemen
they're a mess of rains we're in the
midst of a storm there's
lightning please please go home and
nobody wants to go home
they didn't leave look at you some of
the women are a mess
now actually it's true no they look at a
woman she's a mess
but the truth is you look more beautiful
now than you did when you went to the
beauty parlor so you could save a lot of
money
oh my god some of the women here are a
mess
better you just don't know it
you're real you're real did he say urea
that's great
but think of it thunderstorms are coming
please evacuate please leave nobody left
nobody left i'm glad to say you're all
here because you know if you weren't i
would be blamed 100
and why didn't democrats get legislative
approval mandated under the u.s
constitution to be back on the press
election laws they change it without
getting legislative approval
information is coming out now in arizona
georgia wisconsin
pennsylvania and except for weak
michigan state republican senators
i mean can you imagine detroit detroit
they say
is the single most corrupt district area
wayne county in the whole country you
had people that refused to sign
documents saying the
election was over they refused two
people brave people
they refused they said we can't sign
those documents this thing is terrible
detroit philadelphia
we have a u.s attorney in philadelphia
that says he wasn't allowed
to go and check philadelphia right
that's a big statement i'll tell you who
didn't allow him
someday i'll do it at my next rally but
can you imagine this
because you know we have a deep state
too in this country oh yeah
and a deep state they work with the
democrats and the republicans
those are the republicans i don't like
in fact those are republicans that in
many ways
are worse than the democrats okay
they're worse
totally conspiracy if mitch mcconnell
had the courage and the guts
and if he was a real leader he would
have wanted to look into all the
corruption that took place he knew about
it
during the presidential election a lot
of these people sitting over here they
looked into it and they said that's real
and our country may very well have been
in a much different position than it is
today
i would have been vetoing every one of
those bills that was sent
oh people have spotted this woman here
looks very bored as well yeah
i think the most bored people are blue
shirt guy
and then probably this woman oh she
looks like she even is doing like the
migraine headache type of motion
okay this is so far left to bernie
sanders he's going around saying i can't
believe this is the greatest thing
that's ever happened
i told you instead mcconnell rushed in
and approved of biden and he looked at
the stuff he said we have to get back to
running our country really
and you had the 17 executive orders
immediately signed
and then day after day after day he was
signing executive orders
that were destroying our country i would
have vetoed
every single legislative approval
sent to my desk and we wouldn't be
having any problems
at the border with the economy with the
inflation we wouldn't be having any
problems we would have a country
the likes of which nobody has ever seen
before
it's very sad mitch mcconnell even the
applause lines are
they're losing steam now trump's got a
rap you know we're almost an hour and a
half in
and by the way who shot
ashley babbitt who shot ashley baber
who he's trying to get he's pro he's all
about uh support the police but he's
trying to get a police officer doxxed
now
i spoke to her mother the other day an
incredible woman she's
just devastated like like it happened
yesterday
oh sorry i was checking how long he'd
been going better now we're 20.
strung up and hung okay
now they don't want to give the name
they don't want to give but people know
the name
people know where he came from and it's
a terrible thing right shot boom
there was no reason for it who shot
ashley babbitt it's got to be released
and how come so many people are still in
jail
over january 6 when nobody paid a price
for the
fire and carnage and death that took
place because they couldn't bail
themselves out
including antifa and blm
how come how come
and why are republican leaders like
mcconnell
afraid to take up the subject and talk
about it
disgrace to our country we need
strong leaders we need leaders like
people like this
with me at the top of the ticket not a
single republican house member lost
their race for the first time in decades
not
one we were supposed to lose
25 that's not true some republicans did
lose
right think of it look at that could
that possibly be true
56 phone calls they're called
town hall calls they go to the district
i'd have 10 15 20 000 people every
single call i made
the person won i went to kevin mccarthy
i said kevin
give me every congressman who's down
every congressman who's even and every
congressman who's up by a little
you know can't call everybody it turned
out to be 56 calls
i made 56 calls we didn't lose one seat
if i didn't make those calls you would
have lost 25 to 40 seats
and if i didn't come to the rescue of
the united states senate
this world 50 50 would be 60
40 and mitch mcconnell should never have
lost
those two seats in look at this guy
look at this guy who and this woman i
i'm trying to figure out who's more
who's more disgusted and bored all of
those teletown halls
we received and i received almost think
of this you know they like to say well
the local congressman or the local
representative state rep
he was more popular than trump but they
don't say that they say there's no way
but here's the number it just came out i
received
almost 1.5 million more votes than the
republican house candidates combined
think of that
so in other words i had a man come up to
me
a real pro older guy said sir i was
going to lose my election
i was going to lose by a lot and then
you got involved
it was a state known as arizona and i'm
very proud of those republican
state representatives
the state senate representatives what
they're doing
he said i was going to lose my election
i was going to lose it big sir
and then you came along and you did
rallies and the level of
and i won my election by a landslide but
you were much more popular than me sir
and you won by much less than i did he
said the election
was rigged sir there was no way there
was no way that
it was possible that i got china votes i
only won
because of you and they said i got more
votes
but look at that 1.5 million more votes
i got
and that's okay that's not bragging
that's just to show you how corrupt this
election was we won
ohio in a landslide
we won florida by the largest margin
of any candidate in decades
and only once
many many years ago did a candidate i'm
noticing military guy is clapping with
his head
rhythmically it's sort of like
he's it's a very unusual motion two big
states in ohio
you're a republican you win except for
me
once in history but one that was never
ever was if you in florida you win ohio
and you win iowa i won all three by very
large numbers
nobody has ever lost an election if you
won all three
and i want all three by a lot what i'm
hearing is
it's particularly remarkable the
creative ways in which
trump was able to lose and not stolen
and rigged
you know what we got him by surprise in
2016
and they worked for four years to make
sure that never happens again
and they're not gonna do it i'm watching
this couple very closely
the guy is complaining and the wife is
is looking down at the watch every time
i think he's saying like we gotta go how
much longer is this gonna go on the
the the dynamic between these two is
really it's something
a lot of the people in the audience i
recognize so many
i love this state we easily won the
cuban-american vote in florida including
a mammoth increase in
miami-dade county something that doesn't
happen with republicans
we got a tremendous vote 15 percent of
cuban americans who voted for
crooked hillary clinton in 2016 switched
their votes
to us yet joe biden
who did not even campaign here
supposedly got millions more black votes
than barack hussein obama now let me ask
you
does anybody really believe that biden
got more black votes than
obama blacks for trump clapping
especially in the swing states well they
really came out to vote in the swing
states really i'll say
so he got more votes than barack hussein
obama blue shirt guy checking traffic on
google maps now with his wife how long
is it going to be to get home from this
[ __ ] it's divisive he wasn't divisive
we have a truly sick election system and
it's got to be changed remember
this i am not the one trying to
undermine american democracy i am the
one
trying to save american democracy
right i think this is the start of
trump's wrap-up we can't let them take
away our free speech
so we can talk about corrupt elections
otherwise you'll have that's communism
that's what they do in these communist
countries you have no voice
republicans across the country are
uniting around a plan to secure
every future election with photo id
voter id universal signature
verification
citizenship confirmation chain of
custody
integrity controls update what's the
name of that paradox where you keep
going half the the distance to
to like a wall and if you just keep
going half the distance you'll never
actually get there it sort of feels like
that way like
we're like we're fit we're definitely 50
in we've definitely got another 50
percent
we're at zeno's exactly exactly that's
what this is
look and restoring the time-honored
tradition of
in-person voting on election day
not 30 days before and after
remember trump voted early by mail
conclusion with the help of everyone
here tonight
and patriots nationwide we will elect a
republican house
going to do it we have no choice and a
republican
senate to do all of this and so
much more we're going to bring our
country back with the republican
congress
we will fight for more jobs for american
families
fair trade for american workers and more
american factories forging more products
stamped with that beautiful phrase
made in the usa made in the usa
remember we used to have that we have it
now we're starting to get it back
and then biden got elected they're not
using it anymore
we will hold china accountable you don't
need to use the phrase to do it
pause and charge them 10 trillion
dollars at least in reparation
we will defend american sovereignty we
will secure
america's borders people heading for the
hills illegal
immigrants and they're running what
people are literally running out now
had it just about ended six months ago
we will break up big tech they do seem
to be camera people i'm joking i mean
they seem to be you know getting set up
to film something free
speech in america again which we don't
have
we will protect innocent life we will
defend our constitution we will defend
the second amendment and we will proudly
uphold
the judeo-christian values and
principles
of our nation's founding
we will care for our veterans continue
to strengthen our military
and give our police officers border
patrol ice
and law enforcement our 100 percent
support right we will restore
patriotic education to our schools
these are the same things he promised
before losing by 8 million votes
their country honor our history and to
stand tall and strong
for our great american flag
245 years ago tomorrow
56 brave patriots in philadelphia
proudly declared our independence and
boldly proclaimed the eternal truth
that we are all made equal by the
almighty hand
of our creator
[Music]
[Applause]
for eight long years of the american
revolution
tens of thousands of ordinary citizens
fought bled and died in an epic struggle
against the most powerful
military on the face of the earth they
were the most powerful
they were farmers who bravely stood
their ground at lexington green
and concord bridge they were soldiers
who marched barefoot through ice and
snow
to seize a pivotal victory in trenton
and they were selfless patriots who did
it all
so that we the people would forever rule
our great country
it's truly pablum right i mean it's it's
just it's it's completely uninspiring
is an entrenched interest that anyone
can imagine
but no matter how big or how powerful
they may seem
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them
actually not even pablum suggests
there's something intellectual about it
and there's not
close to you it's like not even
red meat it's trash meat it's your
history it's your heritage
and our magnificent american liberty is
your god-given
right you fought for it
the citizens of the united states of
america will not be dictated to
and talked down to by corrupt politician
tyrants left-wing bullies or socialist
bureaucrats
in washington d.c i know many of them i
don't like them much
our forefathers are the people who gave
us the world's most
majestic and enduring constitution
they are the men and women who cross the
rockies and covered wagons and who faced
unimaginable dangers to win the wild
west
and who tamed the wilderness forged the
steel
laid the railroads dug out the canal
raised up
the skyscrapers and built america into
the greatest nation
in all of history and we are not going
to let it go
[Applause]
well you lost
our ancestors cross just
absolutely crushed fascism beneath the
weight
of american tanks they toppled communism
by the sheer strength of
american culture and now we will defeat
woke radicalism by the sheer power
of american pride and it's happening
americans settled the new world we built
the modern world
and from right here in florida we
launched american astronauts to proudly
salute
our stars and stripes on that very
beautiful give me a
room there is no mountain we cannot
climb
there is no summit we cannot reach there
is no enemy we cannot match
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is
nothing we cannot do
is he lifting this stuff from biden's
speeches because this is very biden-like
and our hearts bleed red white
and blue
we will not bend we will not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up
we will never back down we will never
ever surrender
my fellow americans our movement is far
from over
in fact our fight has only just begun
you know that um we are one movement one
people one family and one glorious
nation
under god so with love of
america swelling in our hearts and the
spirit of
july 4th 1776 stirring in our souls
i say these words to you tonight
we will make our elections
free and safe again
we will make america powerful
again seems like satire we
will make america wealthy
again when he's done let's see if blue
shirt guy even claps
make america strong again
we will make america
proud again
we will make america
safe again man this is so good
we will make america
great again thank you sarasota
thank you florida enjoy the fireworks
thank you everybody
thank you very much
blue shirt guy's not even clapping isn't
[Music]
[Applause]
he
oh my god um hard to imagine anything
less
uh less inspiring than this nonsense and
the uh
[Music]
[Applause]
the trump one flag is like a bit much
for me really
um if b oh oh is he back no he's not
if people are heading out make sure if
you've been thanks for being with us if
if you uh are watching on twitch make
sure to just give us a follow
you will um just more easily see when we
do streams in the future give us a
little
little follow over on twitch if you're
watching on youtube make sure to hit
that subscribe button
we are trying to get to 1.5 million
subscribers sooner than later i would
love to get there
why not right uh and of course the
coupon code
sad trump if you want to revel in the uh
just
sad nature of what we're seeing tonight
you can use the code sad trump on my
website
fran balderrama just used that code and
became new member
149 to sign up today i'll thank a few
other people paul horn and we lost the
video there
is trump back
everybody gets today he's just standing
there like an idiot okay
um venus blood flow is a new member
um caroline mcmahon sandra king
so many great people kelly bedsole uh
just folks i miss
missed during the uh ranting during the
screed
calendar dash jeremy lopez
who else did i miss judy i got
emily aryan bradley bostick
i did i thanked amanda pancake steven
smith
sheila owen just all sorts of great
folks really really very much appreciate
that coupon code good till midnight
sad trump and we will see everybody back
very very soon let's see what's
happening
[Music]
the crowd heading for the hills
mass exit is taking place
dear god what a depressing event
all right anyway good night everybody
follow subscribe tweet
drink water all of that stuff all right
we'll see everybody soon